Ogg
ja es war eigentlich gar nichts mehr großartig dann dachte nur da kommt noch was da was war dann
gar nichts mehr großartig aber ich mein besser so als umgedreht oder besser besser denkt man hat
dunce als man hat wirklich dunce ist ein bisschen was anderes an ein bisschen wo wo wo oder so
irgendwas ein bisschen was anderes als nintendo gedudel heute was glaube ich vor lautstärke auch
ganz gut herr fortnite na klar bin ja bekannt dafür großer fortnite liebhaber zu sein wusste
ihr das noch nicht bin der nummer eins fortnite fanboy ich weiß gar nicht was ist denn leute ihr
müsst mir was wir müssen wir helfen früher ja als die ganzen call of duty quickscope geschichten
angesagt waren da gab es ja immer so meme namen so xx hd quickscope i scope 360 und solche dinge
wie ist der entsprechende meme name für fortnite da gibt es ja doch garantiert auch so was es wird
halt nicht i 360 quickscope quickscope hd oder so sein vor allem hd heute ist ja nicht mal 4k
irgendwie was besonderes heute muss das schon heute muss das schon 8k ultra ultra weit super hd sein
dass es da gibt es doch garantiert auch so was für fortnite was entsprechendes was dem xx hd
quickscope von call of duty früher entspricht entspricht von der benahmung no skin no skin ok
kein plan ja ich auch nicht ich auch nicht dachte vielleicht wisst ihr das
und ich habe jetzt ganz schön viel geschrieben die letzten tage ich sehe das grad bei mir
müsst ihr euch mal gucken hier schaut euch das mal an wirklich mal falsches falsches tab
guckst du mal hier ne wollte ich überhaupt nicht hin
pappas kreditkarte ist das in fortnite wirklich so schlimm also ich weiß dass es die ganzen
kinderspieler meinte die kaufen sich alle skins heimlich oder was heißt heimlich alle nur noch
skins mit pappas kreditkarte man davon abzählen man kann auch bestimmt mit was anderem als kreditkarte
bezahlen guckt euch das mal an guckt euch das mal an heute gestreamt gestern gestreamt
vorgestern gestreamt vor vor vorgestern gestreamt vor vor vor vor vor jetzt was auch immer ich
habe die letzte woche fast durchgehend bis auf immer mal so ein tag zwischendurch fast durchgehend
streemords gemacht sagen gibts ich selbst gar nicht gedacht dass das so viel gewesen ist
und und und teilweise auch recht lang hier wir haben wir dreieinhalb stunden drei stunden
45 also das ist das ist ja für meine verhältnisse ist es enorm viel gibt andere streamer die schaffen
es irgendwie am tag sieben stunden zu streamen oder ich weiß ich weiß nicht wie das gehen soll
ok die spielen auch meistens irgendwas ich gehe mal davon aus sieben stunden am stück spielen auch
wenn ich meine probleme habe sieben stunden am stück sitzen zu bleiben mittlerweile aber ich
könnte mir vorstellen nach sieben stunden am stück gaming zeug machen noch besser geht als
high IQ technik shit oder was hier nebenlos die die die die ganzen die chess grills werden
mir empfohlen hier weiß ich wie die drauf kommen dass ich jetzt jetzt chess gucken will
aber gut mein warum nicht ich will mich zwar nicht über high IQ chess content beschweren
gibt deutlich nervigeres auf twitch als chess content
was ist der vorteil von uefi versus bios hast du nicht gestern schon mal gefragt
immer noch ist das immer noch angesagt wundert mich weil von vor eins von vor eineinhalb
jahren war das angesagt als xqc auch mal chess gelernt hat da wusste nicht dass es immer noch
angesagt aber warum nicht ich mein chess ist ja quasi seit jahrhunderten quasi weiß ich wie
lange es wirklich das schon gibt und gespielt aber ich habe jetzt einfach mal seit jahrhunderten
beliebtes game warum soll das nicht auch auf twitch ankommen was ist der vorteil von uefi
versus bios kannst du maus im bios benutzen es ist ein neuer es hat so komische sachen wie
secure boot und sowas und sag mich nicht keine ahnung das einzige was mir bei uefi immer auf
den keks geht ist wenn das ding die boot partition beziehungsweise die boot disks vergisst die
entries im boot manager bei irgendeinem bios upgrade und dann erstmal gucken dass sie die
wieder rein kriegst da fand ich fand ich diese stumpfe booten vom ersten device per mbr übers
bios fast noch angenehmer dynamische partitionsgröße was hat eine dynamische partitionsgröße mit
uefi zu tun wenn wie groß ich meine partition mache liegt doch an meinem an mir und nicht an
meinem uefi mal gucken weiß ich nicht genau muss mir das erst mal in ruhe noch ein bisschen weiter
angucken 15,3 stunden das ist ganz schön viel überlegt euch das mal das ist fast das ist fast
das ist was heißt fast ich arbeite ja nur 32 stunden ich habe quasi die hälfte von
meiner normalen arbeitszeit noch mal gestriemt das musst du auch erst mal hinkriegen also
es ist jetzt nicht nicht so einfach mal aus dem ermel geschüttelt ja nächste woche dann
wahrscheinlich bisschen weniger zumindest am montag montag gehe ich ja nach frankfurt zur
neuen arbeit und da werde ich dann wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so früh daheim sein sondern wahrscheinlich
erst irgendwie so 16 30 oder sowas und ob ich da abends noch bock habe auf streamerino keine
ahnung weiß ich nicht genau wenn ihr linux benutzt ganz wisst ihr wisst ihr was schon mal was schon
mal gut finde also stolmen wäre stolz auf dich dass du sagst es knu linux allow me to interject
for a moment i like to call it knu plus linux oder wie auch immer das geht ja ich benutze
hauptsächlich tatsächlich artsch by the way wir können mal die vm starten wo wir gerade dabei
sind ich starte mal die vm ich muss glaube ich ein bisschen weniger dauer schwätzen merkt
das teilweise übelst anstrengend nach drei stunden wenn ich ich rede ja ohne punkt und komme
die meisten streams aber nicht weil ich mich zwinge dazu sondern weil das irgendwie so irgendwie so
mir natürlich so vorkommt das so zu machen keine ahnung wie man das beschreiben soll aber es ist
nicht weil ich muss muss muss ich ja gar nichts kann ich muss ich gar nichts sagen wobei dann
würde wahrscheinlich auch keiner zugucken wenn ich gar nichts sagen würde so wo man bei der
gelegenheit mal ein rechner neustellen wir starten wir starten mal die vm neu das kann
nichts schaden an der runde reboot also ich benutze ehrlich gesagt hauptsächlich artsch linux
allerdings nicht für server logischerweise man für server macht sich jetzt artsch linux man
geht als jedes linux auf dem server betreiben beziehungsweise jeden rechner als betreiben hat
wenig mit der linux distribution oder der hardware zu tun aber da ist jetzt artsch vielleicht nicht
so das beste so ein rolling release auf dem server wo man auch will dass es dauerhaft gut läuft jetzt
eher nicht so eine gute idee aber auf dem desktop auf dem desktop auf jeden fall ist das sehr
sinnvoll artsch linux zu verwenden ansonsten auf dem server verwende ich ehrlich gesagt am
liebsten mittlerweile debian oh guck mal das series max hat improvements committed
at rocky 8 und 9 hatten wir das nicht schon sogar ach nee nee all mal linux hatten wir
high IQ shit hier es wird pull requested
luna lobster heißt das nächste ubuntu stimmt das ist endlich mal ein guter name die letzten
releases haben wir ja nicht gefallen von der benahmung her aber aber luna lobster ist war
wieder ein guter name jellyfish gemi jellyfish geht auch aber dazwischen waren ein paar die
waren so nicht sagen aber luna lobster finde ich nice habe ich mich hier vertippt mit mit
fedora
ach ja rocky hat tatsächlich qk images sehr schön wusste ich gar nicht
wir haben sogar wir haben sogar eine hilfe jetzt mittlerweile auf der reine güte
wirds aber advanced hier langsam
ach so das meinst du ok
gut ich frage mich halt braucht man das oft wahrscheinlich nicht aber es ist schlecht dass
es gibt hast du einen tipp für loc locals in
also ich habe immer englische sprache deutsches tastatur layout das ist aber wahrscheinlich
nicht das was du wissen willst moin ich habe gerade gesehen du hast den pull request aufgemacht
vielleicht können wir den heute noch merchen und gucken dass es dann version keine ahnung
0.0.3 gibt und um unsere art steinungs package testen zu können also um noch mal kurz darauf
zurück zu kommen ich muss mich ja leute ich muss mich ein bisschen zurückhalten mit mit
mit schwätzen also ich rede die ganze zeit sonst in den stream so super fast schon so
super excited presentation mäßig ja ich muss mich ich muss mich ein bisschen beruhigen
ich muss nicht ich muss nicht nach einer sekunde ohne wort denken so nach dem motto weiter weiter
reden wobei ich machs ja gar nicht mal so sehr ich laber ja nicht so krass viel die ganze zeit
weil ich denke das muss jetzt so sein sondern irgendwie irgendwie überkommt mich dann immer
so aber ich muss mal ein bisschen beruhigen weil ansonsten geht das auch wenn man jeden
Tag streamt für zwei drei stunden echt ein bisschen auf den hals wenn man jeden
tag drei stunden durch durchgängig labert manche streamer wie gesagt labern irgendwie
acht stunden am tag weil die halt auch nicht wirklich die ganze zeit so ohne luft zu holen
will ich den ganzen stream schwätzen
gut mit gpt hast du ja immer vier 4mb oder so da reicht es ja dicke für alles mögliche aber
hast du mittlerweile eine lösung für deine zähler standerkennung gefunden nee also was
ich ausprobiert habe ist open flamingo das ist eine hier gab es das ach nee keine ahnung ja das
ist irgendwas auf so einem model von facebook basierende image erkennung da gab es auch online
da gab es auch online demos von da habe ich ein paar zählerstände hochgeladen wobei zähler stand
es ist kein zähler stand das habe ich auf twitter so geschrieben weil die meist die
meisten leute was mit anfangen können es ist nicht wirklich ein zähler stand was ich mit
image erkennung machen will sondern ich habe an der heizung so eine druck druckanzeige heizung
sowas sowas ja genau sowas in der richtung sie sieht sieht mehr oder weniger so aus ja so
so ein ähnliches ding habe ich bei mir an der an der heizung und ich will ablesen wo das ist also
ich habe es halt auch so von null bis vier unter bei mir ist es eigentlich immer so zwischen eins
und zwei und der hintergrund ist hier ein bisschen schwarz aber man sieht die nadel also ein mensch
der auf das bild guckt kann dir sofort sagen das ist 1,2 oder sowas ja so und ich habe ich
habe also ich habe fotos gemacht von von dem ding mit verschiedenen zeigerständen und ich
habe dann diese modell versucht zu erklären so nach dem motto hier sieht man eine analoge
anzeige mit mit schritten also mit werten von null bis vier jeder zwischenschritt ist null
2 und auf welchem wert steht die nadel akte habe ich probiert also es hat es hat überhaupt nicht
funktioniert ich setze ein bisschen auf auf gpt 4 wenn die endlich image input supporten da hat
uns ja ich habe sie im letzten stream schon gesagt da hat uns ja microsoft nee wer wer ist jetzt ja
open ai halt ist glaube ich zum größten teil microsoft bis hin schibatet mit der gpt 4 ankündigung
weil gpt 4 kann halt gar keine bilder zum aktuellen zeitpunkt die haben groß getönt dass gpt 4 ja
auch die dinge heißen open ai wie open sie sind das trainierte model ist auf jeden fall nicht
open naja und die haben ja angekündigt das wird bilder unterstützen und das sah auch in der
präsentation so aus als als würden sie direkt bilder können sie haben das ja quasi damit fast
schon beworben dass man jetzt bilder input machen kann aber das geht noch nicht und mal gucken wann
das kommt ich aktuell ist es nur so dass wohl spezielle leute mit developer api zugang und
speziellen ja freischaltung das bekommen ich finde es doof weil ich spekuliere ja drauf dass
gpt 4 eine heizungsdruckanzeige erkennt das wäre wirklich das ist das wird der ultimative test für
gpt 4 imageerkennung ne das bringt genau das bringt nichts weil ich dann an der heizung
rumschrauben müsste da müsste ich irgendwie das ding abschrauben ich weiß gar nicht wo ich
da schrauben muss und ich will auch ehrlich gesagt nicht an der heizung rumschrauben weil das ding
ist ja eingebaut in die heizung da müsste ich irgendwie ding ding die klappe aufmachen und da
was dazwischen bauen ich habe keine ahnung was passiert wenn ich das abschab einfach eine abzweigung
dazu ich weiß nicht wie einfach das ist weil ich mein da muss ja irgendwie dass das ding abmachen
und dann entweicht da irgendwie noch der druck oder so keine ahnung ich will eigentlich nicht an
meine heizung rumschrauben hat gpt 4 macht mal ein fot ja das sieht ungefähr so aus das teil
ich habe ich habe ein bild aber da erkennt man glaube ich nicht so viel drauf chat ich
ah ne das habe ich auf dem tablet
das bild habe ich auf dem tablet das habe ich hier gar nicht kann bild machen ich kann
bild machen easy pass auf ich mache bild easy kann doch einfach auf die kamera gucken ja
guck so sieht das aktuell aus so sieht das aus ja ist gerade ein bisschen unscharf aber so sieht
es so sieht es aus man erkennt da nicht wirklich vieles hat eingebaut in der heizung ich das geht
nicht dass ich mich nicht ablenken lasse so sieht das aktuell bei mir im keller aus und
ein mensch erkennt sofort dass wenn ich ihm sage das ist 1 bis 2 und 0,2 schritte erkennt
er sofort das steht auf 1,4 es ist siehst du siehst du sofort aber ich habe bis jetzt noch
keine ai gefunden die das auslesen kann
es kein rohr zu erkennen ja da muss man aufklappen unter hinten ich kann dir sagen was das für eine
heizung ist das ist eine wie ist man wie todens 200f oder irgendwie sowas es 200f 200w so was
so was könnte das eventuell theoretisch sein ja ich glaube so so sieht das innen drin aus
irgendwie so also da daran rumschrauben ist keine allzu allzu schlaue idee aber heute ich
wollte noch was zu dieser zu dieser sache sagen also was wir heute machen wir bauen
heute ein arch user repo package wir machen mehrere sachen wir bauen ein arch user repo package das
gibt es teilweise schon also ich habe heute morgen schon ein bisschen gebastelt wir
weiter dann unseren github workflow dass das ding auch automatisch updated werden kann
dann bauen wir noch ein paar schöne badges ein im projekt dass das schicker aussieht
vielleicht bauen wir noch 1 2 kleine features ein in den vm champ dass wir das ist rechtfertigt
0.0.3 zu bauen um zu testen ob das updaten vom package funktioniert ehrlich gesagt ich
sollte mal langsam auf version 1 hochgehen weil dann kann ich die hinteren stände eben mit
patches machen so ist so ein bisschen doof so muss ich halt immer für jeden scheiß hochzählen
so ich wollte aber noch kurz dazu was sagen lizenz das ist eine gute idee lizenz
wir legen die lizenz fest ja erinnere mich mal nachher dran
so also ich wollte noch was zu der thema zu der thematik sagen welches welches linux sich
für was eignet es ist wie bei vielem man muss gucken was man machen will also nicht nur so
also nicht nur gucken ist es ein serversystem oder ist es irgendwie ein desktopsystem und
ist es die sondern muss auch gucken was man dafür anwendungszwecke hat zum beispiel nur
mal so was praktisches zu sagen ich habe lange zeit im wohnzimmer so was hier stehen gehabt
das ist es sieht ein bisschen hässlich aus aber wenn eine festplatte drin ist und man das
noch zu macht sieht es gar nicht mehr so hässlich aus das ist im prinzip ein ein festplatten gehäuse
mit einem mit einem so eine art raspberry pile mit einem single board computer hinten dran mit
sata schnittstelle das ist quasi so sie um sich sein um sich sein eigenes mini nass zu bauen
und das ding hat acht kerne also das ist sogar schneller als ein raspberry pile zumal als
ein damaliger raspberry pile gewesen ist gar nicht so also 100 100 mbit kriegst du also gigabit kriegst
du damit locker easy voll sogar teilweise mit verschlüsselung zumindest worauf ich raus will
ist ich habe das ding ja nicht im wohnzimmer liegen gehabt just for fun sondern das war zum
aufnehmen von dvbc oder von kabelfernsehen zum aufnehmen da war tv dann drauf und festplatte
dran und per usb war ein dual tuner angeschlossen für dvbc so und normalerweise könnte man jetzt
sagen und habe ich auch versucht wir nehmen was klassisches ja wir hauen ubuntu drauf oder wir
hauen debian drauf und gut war er aber ging nicht wir haben einen neueren körner gebraucht der
updatete geupdatete dvbc treiber hatte das heißt da muss man wirklich so ein system was eigentlich
für 24 stunden sieben laufen ist damals tatsächlich mit einem artschlinux ausstatten weil wir was
wirklich neues gebraucht haben mit den eingebauten körnl modul mit den neuen also es hängt ein
bisschen davon ab was man machen will normalerweise so auf nur nach 15 x86 hardware wo man jetzt nicht
irgendwie spezielle hardware treiber oder so braucht sondern das meist ist ja schon seit
jahrzehnten im linux körnl drin was man so braucht zumindest an den klassischen intel
netzwerkarten treiber realtech und was es nicht noch gibt dann ist debian eine super
geschichte für server betriebssystem mit debian ich habe jahrelang gerne auch ubuntu verwendet
auf dem server ich fand ubuntu lange zeit war eine super kombination aus aktualität und lange
support also sprich die dinger waren immer relativ aktuell als sie rausgekommen sind und
nicht wie debian was schon irgendwie uralt ist wenn es erscheint und ich fand auch die
paketauswahl und wie das standardmäßig vorkonfiguriert war und da wenig wie man was
macht und da ubuntu jahrelang wirklich gut gemacht so dass ich ubuntu auch auf serversystem
vorgezogen habe gegenüber debian mal im enterprise business umfeld außen vor da ist es gerade im
finanzbranche ist es da sehr viel cento s und original redhead oder aber auch manchmal habe
ich da suze gesehen aber ganz selten aber das meiste ist redhead bzw cento s cento s gibt es
jetzt ja nicht mehr in der älteren form so aber nachdem es ja canonical die letzten jahre über
so verkackt hat mit ubuntu habe ich gar keinen bock mehr drauf ubuntu auch auf servers zu
verwenden das hat angel das hat alles angefangen mit diesem leidigen thema snap packages dass die
immer mehr sachen die man haben wollte in snap packages verpackt haben davor hat schon angefangen
mit netplan für die für die netzwerk konfiguration wenn wir um alles auf die ist auf die idee
gekommen dass es eine gute dass ein guter gedanke ist die netzwerk konfiguration in
irgendeinem undurchsichtigen jammelfail abzubilden snap packages dann die sachen mit netplan und wenn
ich jetzt ein bisschen nachdenke fällt mir bestimmt noch mehr ein und da ist ubuntu für mich so ein
bisschen unattraktiv geworden deswegen habe ich gesagt weißt du was wir nehmen jetzt wieder den
klassiker debian und ich mache mittlerweile die meisten kisten wenn ich die auswahl habe wieder
mit debian drauf und auf dem desktop gibt es eigentlich gar keine frage auf dem desktop ist
es arch by the way eigentlich immer arch ist auf dem desktop super gerade in der vm ist das toll
weil da machst du ab und zu mal einen snapshot sollte es mal wirklich nicht gehen nach dem update
aber das hatte ich noch nie ich hatte legit ich verwende das jetzt jahrelang schon also wirklich
lange seit kann ja zehn jahren vielleicht noch nicht aber ja
sagen wir mal seit sechs sieben jahren verwende ich art schon und ich hatte noch nie das wirklich
durch ein update das system kaputtgegangen ist ich meine die chancen dort sind höher als bei anderen
dank rolling release aber bis jetzt bis jetzt noch keine probleme gehabt ja
was ich von pipp halte ist das package manager für python ja es ist ein package manager genauso
was wie cargo oder gem oder sonst was dir bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig wenn du
sachen installieren willst die ist vielleicht nicht in deinem package manager gibt oder npm
oder sowas ansonsten muss ich sagen also was ich bisher mit pipp gesehen habe war ein bisschen
umständlich wenn man das mal mit anderen package managern vergleicht aber ist halt so
ja umgeht pack man aber was willst du machen wenn es in den repos das package nicht gibt
minus minus force wenn nichts geht minus minus force
vor einem snapshot machen ich will ja nichts selbst programmieren ich will ja
irgendwie haben die das bild erkennt und zuverlässig ist selbst irgendwas gebastelt
habe ich keinen bock drauf in dem fall ne das funktioniert nicht du meinst du meinst das hier
du meinst das hier ne das funktioniert nicht das funktioniert mit zahlen oder
nur mit runden solchen analog anzeigen die durchgehende ne ne das funktioniert nicht
gescheit damit sind diese china chinesen android boxen nicht bissel viren versäugt
ich weiß jetzt nicht wie du drauf kommst aber ich würde es nicht wundern wenn irgendwelche
china chinesen handys backdoors drinnen hätten gerade die super billigen und noch
weitgehend unbekannten hersteller hier doch dann bist du der einzige der snap mag chat mag
noch jemand snap von euch und diese die canonical ubuntu snap geschichte wie sie die netzwerk
konfiguration unter arch aus ich benutze einfach network manager und macht man darüber keine
gedanken hatte mit snap nur probleme ich auch mich nervt das dass viele sachen
unter ubuntu noch als snap ausgeliefert werden wie zum beispiel browser und sowas
endeavor hat mich nicht überzeugt wir haben sie im stream ausprobiert
es gab letztens ein problem mit krab glaube ich da war was ich erinnere mich das war es auch
ist ein halbes jahr her da hat ihnen krab update bei manchen leuten das system zerlegt
also es kommt immer mal wieder vor deine meinung zu linux viren doch sie nicht so verbreitet also
unter linux bist du immer noch am sichersten unterwegs aktuell das liegt an zwei sachen
es liegt einmal dran dass linux weniger verbreitet ist aber es liegt auch daran es
liegt an drei sachen einmal dass linux weniger verbreitet ist das zweite dass linux generell
ganz gute sicherheitsmechanismen hat und das dritte ist was wenn aus aber auch hat muss man
sagen wenn windows ist da auch ich will nicht sagen windows fast noch mehr das kann man so
nicht sagen aber windows auch aber windows ist halt deutlich mehr beschuss ausgesetzt aber das
dritte ist und das finde ich ist eigentlich das wichtigste dass linux user wenn sie linux
use user user werden und wenn sie ja keine linux user logischerweise meistens ein bisschen mehr
ahnung von technik haben beziehungsweise ein bisschen mehr interesse dran und dementsprechend
sie nicht auf die 0815 scams reinfallen das heißt die linux user sind in der regel schlauer und
fangen sich deswegen auch weniger viren ein was heißt schlauer technisch versierter
doch doch doch doch Ubuntu binaries laufen auch unter artsch das die in der meite meiten
fällen schon warum sollten Ubuntu binaries nicht unter artsch laufen also natürlich es
gibt fälle da ist das so wenn du abhängigkeiten hast von einem binary zu bestellen bestimmten
library versionen und die ist dort zu alt oder nicht nicht vorhanden oder so ja das ist das
ist immer so aber du hast mittlerweile viele ja umgebung die also sei es jetzt neuerdings
die scharp seit dotnet dotnet 8 oder auch go go ist ja wohl so der vorreiter schlechthin was
das angeht die haben unabhängige binaries die du auf allen distributionen benutzen kannst also
die laufen schon also du kannst schon binaries von einer distribution auf die andere schieben
zum größten teil ne also gut es kommt ein bisschen drauf an was es ist aber wenn es
ist auf gar keinen fall geht einfach so und viele sachen gehen auch so die die leute bauen
dann einfach linux binaries und keine und keine expliziten binaries in artsch binaries aber was
die leute machen ist die versteht die bieten verschiedene packages an die bieten Ubuntu
Debian packages an oder er p.m. rettard fedora packages oder so was aber wenn du binaries hast
da lau da läuft vieles auch kost distributions mäßig
also die werden wahrscheinlich lauffähig sein
nun gut
rechner neu gestartet vm champ am start mit pull request
der richtige name ist go und es ist go lang nur aus dem grund damit man danach suchen kann
weil niemand kann nach go suchen nach go lang schon wie sieht go quelltext aus du gehst auf
google und gibst ein go example und guckst dir das erste beispiel an
ja bei lp ein linux wäre ich tatsächlich ein bisschen vorsichtig ich habe da in letzter
zeit immer mal so ein paar lame posts drüber gelesen dass die leute mit lp ein linux probleme
bekommen haben nicht ist jetzt nicht security technisch oder so wie sich aus dem kontext
sondern mit dns auflösung weil lp ein verwendet ja keine normale c library sondern die haben
hier ihre musel gelibc oder nie nehmen wir mal gelibc ist das normale und musel libc ist das
was lp ein verwendet was sonst irgendwie niemand außer lp ein verwendet oder musel oder wie man
das ausspricht also wahrscheinlich für für wahrscheinlich für micro c ach keine ahnung
für das steht und die haben tatsächlich probleme mit dns auflösung wenn die dns anfrage ich glaube
mehr als 512 byte ist der dns request oder die response
bin mir gar nicht sicher wie viel es waren oder 1024 byte dann mag lp ein nicht und deine dns
requests gehen nicht richtig und in zeiten von komisch generierten namen heutzutage heißen
ja klaut vms irgendwie so punkt so punkt so da kann das schon mal passieren je nachdem wenn
es auch mehrere records gibt dass das nicht so nicht mehr reinpasst und lp ein probleme macht
also aus dem grund würde ich mir zweimal überlegen aktuell wirklich lp zu verwenden zumal der
riesen vorteil von lp eigentlich also lp einer zwei vorteile einmal es ist ein bisschen so die
zähler vielleicht ein bisschen exotisch und es ist besonders minimalistisch das heißt es bietet
auch weniger angriff fläche aber die die zweite der zweite vorteil von lp dass es ebenso ja so
minimalistisch ist und die die images die lp verwenden so klein sind diesen vorteil gibt es
eigentlich gar nicht mehr so extrem seit multistage builds also seit man docker builds machen kann wo
man dann am ende noch mal ein extra image generiert wo nur der output reinkommt den man auch wirklich
haben will kann es auch debian nehmen das ist einer unterm strich vielleicht 15 mb größer als
ein lp ein aber du hast halt mit nix probleme übrigens max bist du noch da das hast du hier
geschrieben hast dürfte nicht so sein oder ja hast schon gesehen hast schon gesehen ja aber das
prognose recht das problem an sich dass man auch kein custom key auswählen kann so das gibt es noch
aber das klang jetzt erst mal wenn es jemand sie wenn es jemand liest kopiert alle private keys die
leute die leute denken alles mal monka es alter was ist da los dabei kopiert das überhaupt keine
private keys ja schiener chinesen tool auf github kopiert erst mal eure private keys
der nimmt nicht den ssh oder nimmt der nimmt publik hieß die idr sa id der sa und id 2 5 6 5 7 8 5 8 5 9 7 0 oder
so auch immer heißen ja ok also chat ich zeige euch noch mal wo wir gestern stehen geblieben
ne ich zeige euch was anderes zeige euch das art user repo was ich angelegt habe guckt mal da
nämlich im vorfeld schon was angelegt packages vm champ guckt mal da es gibt zwei packages gibt
einmal das kit package also das das was immer live baut vom wort hier und ich habe heute morgen auch
eins angelegt maintainer ist da wo bloß und da gucken wir heute dass wir was reingepusht bekommen
ich kann euch auch beweisen dass das funktioniert machen jetzt mal folgendes
guck hier ist die software die wir packagen wollen als arch repo also als arch user repo
package die liegt bei mir aktuell noch lokal hier rum die löschen wir jetzt jetzt ist weg
geht nicht mehr nicht gefunden und jetzt installieren wir das arch user repo package davon
und siehe da wir haben es wieder diesmal allerdings aus einem arch user repo installiert
das habe ich heute morgen glaube sieht man hier irgendwo auch die zeit jetzt 12 uhr 11
nee utc dann ist es 13 uhr 11 was auch immer irgendwann heute vormittag nachmittag oder mittag
mittag habe ich das gemacht was ist besser also ich mag das paru ist das in rust glaube ich
also das habe ich das habe ich lange zeit verwendet das aber sehr old school noch in pearl programmiert
und sowas und jetzt verwende ich das und ich sehe auch kein grund irgendwie zu switchen
na 14 uhr 11 habe ich das aber nicht das habe ich nicht gemacht das war relativ sicher früher
wobei nee kommt hin vergisst was ich gesagt habe 14 uhr 11 ist okay es gibt
ein vergleich zwischen den ganzen hilfstool our helper ok zeigt mal her
ja oder ist es oder ist es jeha so richtig kokona style oder jeha sagen die ja eher
kikona twitch emotes long ago weiß nicht mal wie das geht so da hier da ist ein vergleich also
es gibt ein vergleich zwischen und die machen mehr oder weniger alle das gleich oder also
du kannst eigentlich benutzen was du willst gut ist dass ja urt nicht mehr drinne steht ja urt
das ist auf französisch yogurt man sieht ja auch archlinux fr
aber das wird nicht mehr so ported schon eine ganze weile nicht mehr
ja was haben sie denn hier für ein vergleich drinne zeigt mal her also eigentlich eigentlich
ist es egal was du benutzt oder die können alle mehr oder weniger das gleiche also ist jetzt egal
ob du paru benutzt oder je benutzt oder tritzen benutzt oder pickauer benutzt oder paku was auch
eigentlich wurscht ich benutze das wenn das pogu heißen würde anstatt paru dann würde ich mir
das tatsächlich überlegen aber es heißt nicht pogu ganz schön weird champ die benahmung ja es
ist written in rust aber ich meine nur weil eine software written in rust das heißt nicht
zwangsläufig dass man die verwenden muss ich weiß die die größten tiere unter uns die sehen
das anders aber für mich ist es erstmal zweitrangig in was eine software programmiert wurde solange sie
gut funktioniert und ich eine hab mit der ich mich auskenn und die gut funktioniert sehe ich
erstmal keinen anlass dazu mich da irgendwie nur weil das andere in rust programmiert ist das zu
benutzen und man kann es ja auch nicht sagen als wäre irgendwie super langsam oder das ist ja auch
gar kein problem funktioniert einfach es sei denn sie wurden ja was gibt man kann selbst ohne
probleme heutzutage javascript software verwenden die ist auch ziemlich schnell
man kann sogar guckt euch discord an man kann sogar elektron software ganz gut verwenden
allerdings muss man sagen discord cheated discord hat in der desktop version viele sachen in
note c++ modulen drinne habe ich mir sagen lassen weiß nicht ob das stimmt aber ich glaube das
einfach mal jetzt und ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen dass das discord für die webapp sogar
relativ gut auch schon web assembly verwendet ohne es zu wissen ich rate das jetzt aktuell
kratmer so also
ich würde sagen dann fangen wir mal an also hier haben wir unser user repo was whatsapp desktop
war früher elektron und die haben dann auf native umgestellt 100 mal besser und schneller
geworden ja whatsapp hat ja auch überhaupt keinen sinn warum muss das warum muss das also wobei
damit kann man ja auch telefonieren das hat schon okay dann nehme ich das zurück es hat
schon seinen sinn oder ich kann es gut verstehen dass discord eine elektron anwendung ist
und ich muss gerade mal was gucken
so also ich kann schon
ich kann schon verstehen aber können wir gleich gucken ich kann schon verstehen warum sowohl
whatsapp als auch discord in elektron programmiert das also gerade im fall von discord verstehe ich
verstehe ich gut also ja ich habe mich abgelenkt lassen durch durch zweites
zweites browser fenster hier auf dem zweiten bildschirm also ich kann schon verstehen darum
warum whatsapp desktop und vor allem discord mit einem elektron im browser programmiert
das also das offensichtlichste ist natürlich dass es damit relativ easy ist alle möglichen
plattformen zu unterstützen also du kannst ja wenn du eine elektron anwendung hast kannst du
die easy laufen lassen unter mac windows linux und mit ein paar anpassungen auch auf den ganzen
mobilgeräten der zweite und wahrscheinlich sogar noch ausschlaggebendere faktor warum
discord sich nahezu anbietet das in elektron zu machen ist discord ist eine multimedia anwendung
also sie benutzen audio video bilder alles mögliche so und wenn du audio video selbst
bauen möchtest auch nur die native schnittstellen benutzen möchtest dann wirst du verrückt da
musst du das komplett anders handhaben unter windows unter linux und mech vor allem unter
linux ist abfuck da gibt es 1000 varianten wie du sound machen kannst ja 1000 varianten
wie du aus grafische ausgabe machen kannst wie du videos machen kannst das ist für ein arsch und
deswegen haben die sich zurecht gesagt die discord leute von discord wir machen das mit
elektron weil da können wir das audio video zeug vom browser benutzen das war eine sehr
clevere entscheidung auch wenn vielleicht eine native app theoretisch ein bisschen
speichersparender ein bisschen schneller und ein bisschen mehr responsive wäre es wäre den
aufwand nicht wert gewesen discord ist das perfekte beispiel dafür warum es sinnvoll sein kann auch
große anwendung elektron zu machen inzwischen audio screen share im discord unter keine ahnung
wenn es im browser geht kannst du von ausgehen dass es in discord mittlerweile auch geht belegt
dir mal die müssten selbst programmieren dann würde es wahrscheinlich nie richtig funktionieren
ja aber ist so viel so viel dazu ok also was wir heute vorhaben ist folgendes ich habe eine
software hier in meinem repo drinnen den vm champ es ist egal was er macht und das ziel ist dass wenn
ich einen neuen tag pushe ins git repo aktuell sind wir bei versionsnummer 0.0.2 wenn ich in
neuen tag pushe dann soll folgendes passieren der soll die software bauen unter einem uralt
cento s7 wenn ihr wissen wollt warum uraltes cento s7 dann schreibt in chat dann erkläre ich
es noch mal ich habe es gestern ausführlich gezeigt aber vielleicht war nicht alle dabei
dann soll die software hier in github actions als bild angehängt werden am ende soll noch
irgendwann mal ein neuer release gemacht werden hier auf github und ich möchte dass ein arch user
repo mit der aktuellen software version aktualisiert wird aktuell habe ich hier ein arch user repo von
hand erstellt wir können uns mal das package bild angucken ich habe das zum ersten mal gemacht ich
habe kein plan davon ich habe mir das abgeguckt aus unterschiedlichen quellen ja so sieht das
bildfile aus für ein arch user repo also beziehungsweise für eine software die man
über ein arch user repo verteilen will da muss man an sachen reinschreiben wie das repo heißt
die package version nummer package release description für welche plattform es zur
verfügung gestellt wird die url vom projekt die lizenz welche abhängigkeit man hat und
in dem fall wo man die software herkriegt wenn man sie nicht selbst kompiliert wie unten ist
dann das drinnen was auf dem system installiert wird warum ich da zwei install calls drinnen
habe einmal um das um das verzeichnis zu erzeugen im output und einmal ums rein zu kopieren vielleicht
kann man auch install minus p machen weiß ich gar nicht vielleicht gibt es ja auch so was so
das ist das ziel dass das arch user repo dieses package bild funktioniert habe ich euch ja gerade
gezeigt die software ist unter user bin liegt die also dass das funktioniert jetzt ist nur die
große preisfrage wie kriegen wir das miteinander verzahnt also wie kriegen wir github actions dahin
das ordentlich zu bauen und danach ins art user repo zu laden und eventuell danach auch
noch den github release anzulegen das müssen wir heute rausbekommen wie das funktioniert
und ich überlege gerade mit was wir am besten anfangen ich kann euch mal das package bild
zeigen wie das aussieht
also wenn man das use wenn man das das jeder skit hinter dem arch user repo projekt hier
klont dann bekommt man ein repo mit genau zwei dateien drinnen es gibt einmal pkg bild das ist
das was ich euch eben gezeigt habe und es gibt source info das wird aus pk wird wird aus dem
pkg bild erzeugt noch mal das ist quasi das gleiche nur in anderem anderer form
ja und was das hier macht ist wie gesagt relativ übersichtlich das lädt das programm von github
runter also das hier muss es geben diese zwei sachen damit ich das hier machen kann damit ich
über das über den package manager von archlinux diese software hier installieren kann das es geht
sieht man ja hier und diese zwei dateien braucht man dafür was da drinnen steht ist folgendes
hier steht wo es die software gibt in dem fall ist es halt ein binary release deswegen heißt das
ding ja auch vm champ bin da muss man nix selbst kompilieren das wird fertig runtergeladen von
github hier muss die download version rein in dem fall ist es halt immer hier wo bloß vm champ
releases package version vm champ linux package version amd64 und hier ist dann drinne was
passiert wenn das package erzeugt wird ich kann euch das auch mal zeigen wir können das jetzt
wir können es jetzt von hand machen make make package das ist das was
das ist das was dieses tool hier unter der haube auch aufruft
make package bum und jetzt hat man hier quasi die roh version von diesem package im verzeichnis
liegen man sieht das hat er jetzt aus diesem package bild erzeugt und man kann sich den
inhalt von dem package auch noch mal angucken es ist im prinzip das was man was man erwarten
würde es ist quasi in der fahrt wo das installiert werden soll im endeffekt ist in diesem package
drinnen und das ist das ist quasi in den taget set was der baut und dann taget set was das der
package manager wieder auspackt und bei euch ein system legt das ist halt das wie art packages
funktionieren bei der haube ist das wenn man so will nur ein ich sag jetzt mal zipp auch wenn
es kein zipp ist so eine art zipp da sind zwei sachen drin einmal das programm an sich und einmal
ein link auf das programm noch mal kleingeschrieben so sieht das aus und
klauen wir das noch mal gut
heißt im endeffekt wir können dort weitermachen wo wir gestern aufgehört haben ich zeige euch
mal wo wir gestern aufgehört haben immer mal hier repos vm champ ach so ja ich kann euch jetzt noch
erklären ich weiß ich ob jemand gefragt hat im chat ich kann euch noch erklären warum ich
diese software unter einem uralt cento s7 baue ich zeige euch mal das dockerfile dazu warum will
ich eigentlich immer dicker feil schreiben jepp kocker so dockerfile das passiert beim
bild von der software er checkt ein uralt cento s7 aus dann installiert er ein paar
dependencies installiert dotnet acht preview wie man hier sieht man sieht nicht das preview
ist aber dotnet acht ist gerade im preview dann kopiert er die ganzen source dateien rüber
setzt ein paar magic variablen für dotnet und dann kompiliert er das ganze also hier er
kompiliert das mit dotnet publish für linux x64 release version er soll als versionsnummer das
hier benutzen er soll eine self content executable bauen er soll das ganze zusammen kompilieren in
einer datei er soll paar debug sachen rauslöschen und in output soll also er soll das in den
bild ordner als output schreiben so und danach das ist jetzt trick 17 danach leg ich noch ein
leeres image an mit dem resultierenden binary das binary liegt dann am endeffekt in bild im
bild ordner aus dem resultierenden binary baue ich dann quasi noch ein leeres image damit ich
das gebaute programm aus dem image wieder raus bekomme und das ist alles was in diesem docker
fall passiert so und jetzt ist die frage chat ich sag gleich was zu und jetzt ist natürlich die
frage warum muss ich das bauen mit einem uralt cento s7 das kann ich euch erklären ich benutze
hier ein neues oder was ist ein neues ein erweitertes feature was sie mit dotnet 8 eingeführt
also was sie was sie mit dotnet 8 erweitert haben und zwar sie haben ihren compiler verbessert für
dotnet 8 sie haben sie haben ihren compiler verbessert in dotnet 8 und zwar die binaries
die rauskommen sind jetzt viel kleiner als vorher und die startzeit ist noch schneller was
natürlich eine coole kombination ist es gibt bloß ein problem wenn man diesen neuen compiler benutzt
es klingt jetzt erst mal so als hätte das alles nur super viele vorteile weil ich meine das ist
kleiner es startet schneller und sowas eigentlich ganz toll naja es hat ein nachteil wenn man
diesen neuen diesen neuen compiler in dotnet benutzt man bekommt eine abhängigkeit rein
und das ist eine abhängigkeit auf die gelibc version des systems auf dem man die software
baut und wenn ich das wenn ich die software baue das ist übrigens ein riesen vorteil von
go damit hat man solche probleme nicht go erstellt self contained binaries ohne solche probleme
zumindest in dem fall hat man das problem und man hat eine abhängigkeit auf die gelibc version
des systems auf dem die software kompiliert wurde was natürlich bisschen doof ist weil
ich habe hier gelibc 2.37 das ist sehr neu und es gibt systeme die haben ältere version und da
läuft es dann nicht drauf dann habe ich zwar ein binary aber es funktioniert nicht weil es beim start
sagt ja gelibc symbols not found auch wenn er nichts davon benutzt was die vielleicht anders
machen das heißt der trick ist jetzt wir bauen das in einem ganz alten system und nachdem wir
auch sonst nur als abhängig also nachdem wir auch sonst nur gelibc als abhängigkeit haben holen
wir uns da auch keine open ssl irgendwie sicherheitslücken oder sowas rein wir kompilieren
auf dem ganz alten system auf dem ältesten system was dort nicht acht noch unterstützt
und dementsprechend haben wir ja nur eine abhängigkeit gegen gelib gelibc 2.17 und gelibc
2.17 release date ist von ende 2012 das heißt unsere software läuft auf allen linux system
die neuer als 2012 sind und da gehen wir mal von aus dass es ok ist wenn ich linux distribution
die älter als elf jahre sind nicht mehr unterstütze ich glaube damit können wir leben oder da gibt
es wahrscheinlich noch ganz andere probleme so das ist der grund warum das ganze in einem docker
container gebaut wird ja damit ich die uralt gelibc version von cento s7 benutzen kann cento s6 geht
übrigens an der stelle nicht mehr das wird nicht mehr unterstützt das wäre dann das wäre
wirklich antik schon cento s cento s6 auf meiner alten arbeit hatten wir einen cento s system das
war in cento s6 was sich selbst als cento s4 getan ja doch in cento s6 was sich als redhead
enterprise linux 4 getan hat da da lief eine uralt oracle datenbank drauf für irgendein
wahrenwirtschaftssystem und das wurde nur dreimal im jahr eingeschaltet oder sowas und die lief
nur rückwirkend bis redhead enterprise linux 4 also cento s4 quasi falls es das damals schon
gab und damit wir das weiter betreiben konnten haben wir den cento s6 installiert damals auch
schon vor vor zehn jahren oder so und haben in die etc was ist das etc redhead release glaube ich
reingeschrieben du bist kein cento s6 du bist in redhead enterprise linux 4 und wenn es in der
teil drinne steht dann reicht es oracle dann startet das ist nur alt teil das hat mich
überlebt bei der firma weil ich bin jetzt weg ich bin seit 19 stunden und 50 minuten
nicht mehr angestellt dort kündigung ist raus die kündigung war schon im december raus
und am montag geht es dann weiter woanders da bin ich echt gespannt darauf wie das läuft ja
so viel zu meinem dockerfile und warum das ganze mit cento s7 läuft bist du aufgeregt ja bisschen
schon du hattest ein video gemacht so was wie morgens mein letzter tag wie war er wirklich
relativ normal ich habe mich von den leuten verabschiedet ich habe noch mal in teams in
paar channels geschrieben soll jungs bin jetzt weg ich habe alle ich bin super ordentlich gewesen
ich habe alle meine tickets geschlossen ich habe alle meine tickets geschlossen mit dem hinweis das
ist mein letzter tag im unternehmen wenn es irgendwie noch wenn es da wenn es zu dem ticket rückfragen
gibt und dann bitte neues ticket eröffnen in dem und dem bereich also bin da mit null tickets
mit null tickets raus und ansonsten wie war der letzte tag ganz normal nichts wildes ich habe
mich ein bisschen über die personalabteilung wieder aufgeregt weil sie immer noch nicht
alles fertig haben ist ja normal bei dieser personalabteilung gewesen die war immer ein
bisschen lahm mit allem ansonsten gibt es da nichts großartiges zu berichten war recht
unspektakulär es hat mir ein bisschen leid getan halt weil die ganzen leute sich die haben sich
dann auch alle verabschiedet und so manche haben geschrieben max es war mir eine ehre also so
redewendung mäßig ja habe ich dann auch noch mal mit herzchen geliked im chat obwohl ich das
sonst nicht mache aber es war ganz normaler tag 15 uhr 10 15 15 oder so bin ich abgehauen
zum hauptbahnhof heim gefahren und hatte noch gar nicht so richtig das gefühl das war es jetzt
aber das war es gewesen es ist gewesen bin ans weg mein account geht noch ich habe mich
heute morgen mal versucht über den browser just for fun einzuloggen also deaktiviert haben sie
mich noch nicht mal gucken wie lange sie dafür brauchen bis sie mich deaktiviert haben und vor
allem mal gucken und nein ich habe nichts ich habe nichts eingebaut oder so leute aber ich
bin mal gespannt was kaputt geht wenn sie meinen account deaktivieren weil ich könnte
mir durchaus vorstellen dass unter meinem account noch irgendwo irgendwelche sachen laufen und
getriggert werden die dann nicht mehr funktionieren ich meine ich war da so lang dabei da bleibt es
nicht aus aber da kann ich ja nix für max du kennst dich ja gut mit pcs aus nee nicht wirklich
mit hardware und sowas und gerade mit mit wind auf von wind aus habe ich gar keinen plan vielleicht
warum ich in fortnite mit der 470 ti solche mikro ruckler bekomme nö keine ahnung meine standard
vermutung wäre sie wird zu heiß aber das ist meistens nicht so neuer treiber sie wird
zu heiß keine ahnung ich kann dir auch nur die 115 tipps geben da gibt es leute die kennen sich
besser aus damit du könntest vm-champ nutzen um vm-champ zu bilden das wäre richtig hrq du
meinst ich könnte eine vm anlegen und in dieser vm dann vm-champ kompilieren ja dumm nur dass
glaube ich in github actions nestet virtualisierung nur schwierig doch geht ich glaube nestet
virtualisierung geht sogar in github actions aber ist halt unsinnig langsam
ja das ist halt so warum machst du ich muss mich von dir bedanken gleichzeitig beschweren
ich habe dich vor eins kommen ich habe dich vor eins bis vor noch einer linux anfänger
bin nun an meinem ersten arch install dran der mist lässt lässt mich nicht locker ja du hast
schon mal die eine die einzig wahre giga chat distribution ausgewählt neue mario 8 mario
k8 ne du hast schon mal die einzig wahre giga chat distribution ausgewählt eins kannst du
sicher sein wenn du das ordentlich installiert bekommst wobei es mit dem arch installer eigentlich
geht und dann halbwegs ordentlich eingerichtet bekommst du wie es haben willst dann hast du
schon mal mehr ahnung als 95 prozent aller linux user und und mehr ahnen na gut das kann man so
nicht sagen wahrscheinlich sind sind nicht nur fünf prozent der leute arch user sondern mehr
also hast du jeden fall mehr ahnung als 95 prozent aller computer user ja also aller pc benutzer und
wahrscheinlich auch mehr ahnung als die meisten der linux user wenn du das auf die reihe bekommen
hast du kennst nicht zufällig das problem dass die fritzbox ip adressen außerhalb der dhcp range
vergibt nee warum macht die denn sowas auf diesen geräten komme ich dann nicht außerhalb meines
eigenen netzes wie jetzt ich glaube ich weiß was ich weiß was schief läuft ich weiß was schief
läuft kann das sein dass die ip mit 169 anfängt guck mal nach sag mir mal die ip die da vergeben
wird fängt die mit 169 an ich habe ich habe so ein ganz gutes gespür für solche fehler beschreibung
lasst uns mal gucken ob ich richtig liege mit meiner vermutung er zählt erzähl mal die ip
sk 99 sag mal sag mal die ip von einer fritzbox also was die was die vergeben hat meine vermutung
ist nämlich folgendes dass das dhcp nicht funktioniert und sich deswegen das netzwerk
interface eine wie heißen die dinger wie heißen die 196 ip adressen wie nennt sich das
ich vermute ich nämlich dass es schlicht ergreiflich nicht geht und die einfach sich
so eine link local adresse generaten da ist der dhcp vergibt die adresse nicht sondern das
interface selber aber wahrscheinlich ist sk schon weg weil er nicht fünf minuten zeit hatte zu
warten bis ich seine frage beantworte ane da ist er da ist er doch schon wieder achso ok ich
habe falsch gelegen ich habe falsch gelegen die ip ips die vergeben werden sind unter anderem
178 178 klingt nach fritz fritz box default netz ok ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung wie man
ip ranges angibt in im dhcp von der fritz box keine ahnung aber du solltest da trotzdem
drauf zugreifen können weil das ist ja höchstwahrscheinlich in slash 24 und
dementsprechend trotzdem das gleiche netz oder ist es kein slash 24
gut dann machen wir mal weiter ich zeige euch jetzt wo wir stehen geblieben sind gestern
im stream und an der stelle setzen wir jetzt auch an gestern haben wir folgendes gemacht ich
mache diesen ganzen krempel auf fack so viel wollte ich jetzt eigentlich nicht zumachen
land wir starten an firefox neu start wahrscheinlich wobei ich habe keine ganzen rechner neu gestartet
so was komplett komplett verkehrt also wir sind hier stehen geblieben wir haben für diese
software wie gesagt egal was sie macht haben wir github actions gebaut und zwar haben wir
folgende github actions gebaut recht übersichtlich das ganze noch wir haben eine github action
gebaut die folgendes macht nun mal so recap von gestern folgendes macht die software macht
macht github actions in dem fall bei jedem push von einem neuen tag ins git repo wird dieser
bild job ausgeführt beziehungsweise wird der job ausgeführt der den namen bild hat das ganze
läuft auf einer ubuntu 22 04 vm warum weil das default ist in was heißt die fall die default ist
es nicht aber das eine der vms ist die auf github angeboten werden auf github wird angeboten mac
windows und ubuntu linux und ubuntu gibt es in 1804 20 04 22 04 wir nehmen das aktuell ubuntu
und wir führen dann diese steps hier der reihe nach aus erstmal den ganzen source code aus checken
der im repo drinne ist beziehungsweise den ganzen source code in diese bild vm kopieren dann
zusätzliche docker plugins installieren weil wir das brauchen gleich um das image zu bauen
und dann führen wir dieses script hier aus das script ist relativ übersichtlich das holt
sich aus environment variablen von der github action holt sich den aktuellen tag name raus
das hier ist der tag der gepusht wird also zum beispiel wenn hier tag v003 gepusht wird dann
steht hier unter github revname v003 drinne davon schnippel ich das v vorne weg also ich
nehme cut an character und ich will vom zweiten character bis zum ende alles rausholen das heißt
am endeffekt in target version steht da nicht v003 drinne sondern 003 so dann macht er noch
ein bisschen magic wurscht was er da macht er holt sich ein paar tokens raus die er braucht
und dann baut er sich ein container image mit grundlage eben auf diesem docker file was ich
euch eben gezeigt habe was macht er hier mit diesem kommando docker bild x bild bild x ist
ein plugin für docker das ist das ist das das bild kit plugin damit kann man zum beispiel docker
container bauen ich glaube sogar ohne root rechte und man hat ein paar mehr features zu bieten als
das klassische docker bild das klassische docker bild geht so und mit bild x sieht das ganze halt
so aus und zwar gibt es hier so ein paar kleine unterschiede zum normalen docker bild nämlich
also hier setzt er die target version von dem binary was rausfallen soll das ist jetzt erstmal
egal man kann das ganze cashen denn bild x beziehungsweise wir nennen es einfach mal
bild kit bild kit unterstützt mittlerweile direkt das cashing des container builds in
den github actions cache das ist eine sehr nice geschichte das heißt die builds sind jetzt wenn
man sie einmalig durchgeführt hat auch viel schneller weil er vom letzten bild auf die dort
generierten container images zugreifen kann was sonst ein bisschen problematisch war wenn man
in github actions container baut das war sehr langsam lokal ist es kein problem weil er sich
das ja immer speichern kann aber in github actions ist es ja immer eine vm die die weggeschmissen
wird nach dem jeweiligen so was bei github actions kann man auch eigene docker images zum
beispiel von docker hat nutzen ja kann man machen also jedoch ist dann der job nie gestartet sondern
war immer pending weißt du warum github den job nicht starten möchte sondern immer nur bei
wo wir benutzen heute den docker image wirst du gleich sehen wenn er einfach nur auf pending ist
dann waren wahrscheinlich gerade alle runner belegt das ist das ist schon möglich gerade
wenn man das freetier hat aber normalerweise startet das und gibt einen fehler vielleicht
waren auch vielleicht haben die auch gerade probleme gehabt aber normalerweise ist das kein problem
das funktioniert machen wir heute also wir bauen heute noch was mit einem container image weil
wir brauchen einen arch wir brauchen einen arch container um unser package bauen zu können
so dann bildet er das ganze und was ich euch eben im dockerfall gezeigt habe dieser letzte step
hier dieses fake image dass er den in den output dass er das binary in dieses fake image hier
reinkopiert das brauchen wir an das benutzen wir an dieser stelle hier unten nämlich target output
nach temp output also sprich das kompilierte tool was aktuell noch im container image steckt wird
rauskopiert wieder auf die ubuntu vm zurück nach temp out und danach wird das fertig kompilierte
binary als artefakt also als als zip angehängt an den jeweiligen github actions run dass man
sich das runterladen kann mehr haben wir gestern nicht gemacht und das funktioniert auch ich habe
noch was anderes rausbekommen was noch sinnvoll ist zu machen nämlich dieser cash ist standardmäßig
gescoped auf den branche das heißt wenn ich jetzt in branche habe und dort neue comments pushe und
für jedes kommet wird so ein bild gemacht dann funktioniert das cashing von den von den container
wenn ich allerdings das auf tech basis mache dann funktioniert das zwar mit der gleichen tech
version immer wieder bei normalerweise pusht man die gleiche tech version genau einmal und nicht
wieder und jetzt ist es so man kann das allerdings um umscopen man kann nämlich sagen zum beispiel
hier scope oder sowas wie bild und dann ist es tech übergreifend machen wir jetzt nämlich mal
dass meine bilds in zukunft schneller sind get status wunderbar jetzt machen wir dieses
kryptische dieses kryptische kommando mal damit ich nicht immer von hand triggern muss
gut push und es werden wir gleich sehen was gestern new tech v4 get tech minus dv 0.0.4
geht push minus minus delete ja aber 0.4 weg alles klar so wenn man jetzt mal get up actions
reinguckt sieht man der macht ein bild was er von version 4 nicht machen soll kann man gleich wieder
abbrechen please cancel und jetzt müssen wir den bild mal zugucken wir werden feststellen das bild
ist sehr langsam warum ist das bild langsam gut weil wir noch keinen cash haben also unser
get up actions cash der ist leer den habe ich heute morgen geklärt komplett damit wir heute
noch mal frisch anfangen können und ihr werdet sehen das container bild das initiale dauert
lang das dauert dreieinhalb minuten oder sowas und das nächste dauert dann bloß auf 15 sekunden
also das cashing bringt schon was gut jetzt kann ich noch mal kurz ein paar sachen aus dem chat
beantworten was kein internet auf den ah du hast kein internet auf den geräten weil
der kein geld weil sich bei da cp gezogen hat ja sehr merkwürdig was deine fritz box da macht
gab ja sonst nichts na
ok so gucken wir mal ob das container bild durch ist nein das baut immer noch kommt mal seit zwei
minuten ist es am bilden also ihr seht ein container bild über get up actions ohne cash
ist ab fack langsam also richtig nervig das braucht am ende dreieinhalb minuten oder sowas
das ist halt das hält das hält man halt nicht aus im kopf richtig langsam der shit
irgendwann so nach dreieinhalb minuten ist er dann fertig und dann kann ich euch zeigen dass
der der nächste push viel viel schneller ist und das ist das wo wir gestern stehengeblieben
sind jetzt geht es darum wie bauen wir ein arch user repo package in get up actions wir
könnten es uns einfach machen machen wir aber nicht sage ich auch gleich schon dazu wir könnten
es uns einfach machen und ein feet nein nein nein nein nicht nein nicht cobalt setup das
wollen wir nicht wir könnten es uns einfach machen und ein fertiges ein fertigen bildstep verwenden
aus dem get up actions marketplace das ding nennt sich marketplace das ist aber nichts was was
kostet warum auch immer es marketplace heißt da gibt es nämlich leute die haben schon fertige
actions gebaut zum publishing eines arch user repo packages da könnte man einfach so was hier
reinschreiben package name wäre in dem fall beispielsweise also package name wäre in dem
fall vm champ bin package bild file ist das hier commit username würde ich angeben ssh private key
kann ich angeben zum pushen ist eine schöne sache wenn man keinen bock hat sich damit zu
beschäftigen wie man das selbst machen könnte ich würde sagen wir bauen das mal selbst dann
wird es nämlich schon ein bisschen komplizierter und ja wenn jemand keinen bock hat das von hand
zu machen kann er einfach die get up actions hierfür benutzen und es geht das ist ja das feine an
get up actions viele leute haben schon die sachen im vorfeld für eingebaut und man kann die sachen
wenn man einfach nur schnell was benutzen will ist das eine super geschichte so also mein bild
ist fertig in drei minuten 41 und das passt mal auf das bild hat drei minuten 41 gebaut wir
triggern das bild jetzt noch mal und ihr werdet jetzt gleich sehen wie krass das ganze ist mit
cashing jetzt sollte das bild gleich noch mal laufen so passt mal auf sobald das bild anfängt
sobald das bild anfängt drücke ich mal auf mein timer so beim bild fängt an
postchamp
und bild ist fertig 6 also ich brauche habe ich einen timer gestartet 26 sekunden
ja ich hätte überhaupt kein timer gebraucht aber gut 26 sekunden also sprich allein durch
das cashing meines container builds sind wir runter von drei minuten 59 bild time auf 36
sekunden und ich glaube 36 sekunden ist komplett im rahmen damit kann man glaube ich leben so und
jetzt müssen wir uns damit beschäftigen wie bekommen wir ein arch user repo bild in get up
actions hin dazu öffnen wir mal get up actions ich muss dazu sagen ich mache das nicht komplett
blind ich habe mir da im vorfeld schon ein bisschen gedanken zu gemacht wie man das machen könnte ich
habe es aber nicht komplett zu ende gebaut bis zum push in das in das user repo so die sache ist die
ich habe es euch ja hier gezeigt wie das wie das wie das prinzipiell wie das prinzipiell geht
das arch user repo package zu bauen man muss dieses git verzeichen man muss dieses arch user
repo git auschecken und dann muss man sagen make package mit dem pkg bild und dann muss man noch
eine source info generieren und dann muss man das ganze wieder pushen in das vm champion arch user
repo get repo package was auch immer hier hin auf jeden fall so das heißt das müssen wir jetzt
in einem container machen weil warum müssen wir das in einem container machen das hier ist
eine ubuntu vm und eine ubuntu vm oder oder wie die coolen leute das das nennen würden eine
ubuntu vm die hat kein die hat kein make package und pack mann und so zeug drauf also wir sollten
das in einer arch wir sollten das in einer arch umgebung bauen das package das heißt wir müssen
jetzt einen zweiten build step machen oder kein kein build step sondern einen zweiten
einen zweiten job um das arch user repo package zu bauen ich verschiebe das mal und da mann hier
ah gebeted normalerweise sollte das eigentlich anzeigen dass man hier verschieben kann aber es
gebetet mich kann das kann das verschieben ohne dass es so aussieht als dass ich verschieben kann
aber was auch immer also der erste build shop der baut das der baut die software und uploadet das
ding auf github ja so weit so gut jetzt brauchen wir aber noch einen zweiten job nämlich ein job
den wir jetzt einfach mal aua nennen also für hier das um das ins arch user repo zu pushen
und den ersten step den copy paste ich mir weil der ist ziemlich
simpel den muss ich den muss ich nicht den muss ich nicht tippen und zwar der erste step den wir
brauchen ist folgendes wir müssen das was dieser job hier erzeugt hat müssen wir in diesem job
importieren und das können wir so machen dann sagen action wir benutzen die die action download
artifact und downloaden das was wir hier oben generiert haben nicht in gmail öffnen jetzt
ist das ding es ist immerhin noch eine ubuntu vm auf der das hier standardmäßig läuft wir wollen
das allerdings in einer arch umgebung machen und jetzt muss man ein bisschen was anpassen nämlich
erst mal müssten wir sagen dass das nicht parallel ausgeführt werden darf sondern dass
dieser schritt nach diesem schritt passieren soll standardmäßig ist es nämlich so dass die
steps innerhalb von einem job sequentiell laufen es sei denn man macht irgendwas mit bildmatrix
es ist erstmal so die die steps in einem job laufen sequenziell allerdings jobs dürfen parallel
laufen so das will ich in dem fall jetzt ja nicht weil wenn diese beiden jobs parallel laufen dann
will dieser job was machen mit etwas was noch gar nicht da ist deswegen muss man als erstes hier
mal sagen dieser job hängt von diesem job ab das ist alles das was macht also der job
braucht job bild als ab als dependency als abhängigkeit aber man hätte es auch depends
on oder was auch immer nennen können oder run after oder aber die haben es halt kein needs
needs bild bezieht sich hier der name bezieht sich auf den job hier oben so und dieser job hier
oben lief in einer ubuntu vm das hier unten wollen wir nicht in einer ubuntu vm ausführen
sondern wir wollen naja doch um zwei ecken schon wir wollen wieder sagen wir sagen wir weil
github actions sind immer vms da kann man nichts dagegen machen runs on und jetzt kommt aber der
eigentliche step container archlinux das heißt was hier passiert ist der startet wieder in ubuntu
github actions runner da drauf führt er jetzt allerdings direkt in archlinux container aus
und lässt uns darin zeug machen so wie man das direkt auf einer vm machen könnte und da müssen
wir jetzt ein paar bild steps hinzufügen nämlich wir müssen unser arch user package bauen also am
anfang auf jeden fall github mittlerweile könnte ich mir vorstellen gucken die sich paar sachen
voneinander ab übernimmt er die vm der erstellt immer eine neue vm das ist ja das ist ja der
eigentliche grund warum wir hier den cash für die container builds überhaupt brauchen
das ist jedes mal eine neue vm und da würde jedes mal komplett neu diese container bauen was
halt doof ist deswegen brauchen wir erst den cash deswegen ist es auch so langsam ohne cash
weil es immer eine neue komplett kline vm ist so und bevor wir jetzt hier unsere github action
bauen würde ich sagen starten wir jetzt mal lokal ein docker container genau den wunderbar
das ich hier noch habe eine art schlienungs docker container
die voll vom bildschop
ja das ist immer eine neue du meinst die hier gär die hier auch die gleiche die gleiche wie
hier und auch ja und auch wenn ich einen container verwende ist das immer ein neuer immer ein cleaner
frisch ausgecheckter container du kannst nichts behalten zwischen action runs wenn du was zwischen
action runs behalten willst dann musst du es entweder in den github actions cash schreiben
als artefakt hochladen oder manuell mit cash safe und cash restore wieder herstellen du
kannst auch noch so sachen wie s3 filesystems und so was also du brauchst auf jeden fall was
persistentes außerhalb von github actions damit das funktioniert so funktioniert das funktioniert
das nicht also du kannst nicht die gleiche vm wiederverwenden das ist immer frisch so
wir starten uns jetzt mal eine lokale art schlienungs vm und probieren wir aus wie wir
darauf das package bauen könnten
make package ist schon mal drauf gut also high IQ shit das war überlegen das erste was wir
machen müssen ist wahrscheinlich pack man
geht ist nicht drauf ok das erste was wir machen müssen ist pack man geht installieren gibt es
nicht ok dann ist der erste step package sources updaten da haben wir doch schon mal was das
also build step hinzufügen name make package und da wollen wir jetzt da wollen wir jetzt
kommandos drin ausführen und unser erstes kommando was wir ausführen wollen in unserem
build step ist eindeutig pack man minus sy um den die die paketquellen zu laden so als nächstes
wollen wir git installieren ich kürze das mal ein bisschen ab wir wollen git installieren
sudo installieren das weiß ich schon weil ich mir ein bisschen gedanken im vorfeld drüber
gemacht habe und wir wollen open ssh installieren wait a minute da gibt es eine abfrage das muss
automatisiert gehen pack man pack ein auto yes pack man option to assume yes to every question
minus minus no confirm excellent das brauchen wir das heißt das hier ist der nächste step
den wir machen müssen gut das war so jetzt müssen wir das git repo klonen also wir gehen
mal nach temp ich glaube temp ist ein gutes guter platz dafür git clone das repo
ach moment ich brauche mein ssh key in diesem container ich muss ja ich muss ja was pushen
am am am schluss wieder ok ist es doch ein bisschen komplizierter als ich mir das ganze
vorgestellt habe wir tun mal so als könnte ich pushen so jetzt habe ich das repo ausgecheckt mit
meinem package bild drinne jetzt muss ich im package bild die versionsnummer das kannst du
über ein github secret machen nicht alles verraten ich habe das github secret schon längst
hinterlegt weil ich wusste dass ich den ssh key brauche als volume rein mounten ich weiß gar
nicht github actions volumes wie man damit ob man da ob das was bringt
mounting volumes used container to set an array of volumes for content you can use
volumes to share data between services or other steps in a job also ja will ich ja nicht
ich mache ja alles ich mache ja alles im gleichen step
ja serious max richtig wird camp um nicht zu sagen ob ich das emote
wo ist wo ist das wird wo ist das wird camping emote ihr müsst mir mal kurz ich finde ich
finde meine emotes gerade nicht mehr wo ihr wird camping alles klar da ist es ich habe
es ich habe es gefunden scripted extremst wird camp cringe stream so also wir haben das repo
jetzt ausgecheckt ich würde sagen das machen wir jetzt als nächstes das bringt das bringt an
der stelle nichts wie können wir das package bauen warum gibt es so viele emotes von dem
typen weil das eines der twitch original emotes ist dies jahrelang jahrzehntelang quasi gab oder
sagen wir so na ja jahrzehntelang vielleicht nicht aber dies sehr lange gab und eines der
beliebtesten emotes überhaupt ist leider hat sich der typ ich weiß gar nicht was er erzählt hat
leider hat sich dieser typ auf twitter über irgendwelche dinger nicht ja nicht twitch
kompatibel geäußert ich weiß nicht mehr um was es ging und was er erzählt hat zumindest hat
das twitch nicht gefallen twitch hat die emotes mit ihm entfernt
ach ja genau das war das wo die wo die versucht haben das nicht das weiße haus zu stürmen nee
nee nee nicht dass das andere nicht das weiße haus sondern das andere ja genau ja ja ich erinnere
mich wieder und da hat er irgendwelches komisches zeug geschrieben auf twitter und darauf hat
twitch gesagt den typ wollen wir nicht mal als emote haben und hat ihn rausgekickt es
wurden ja schon ein paar andere entfernt in der vergangenheit aber das war glaube ich zum größten
teil auf eigenen wunsch oder auf rechtliche probleme hin also ich weiß dass winwaker entfernt wurde
als emote falls das noch jemand kennt das da das war kosmo und das wurde glaube ich auf eigenen
wunsch entfernt dann gab es noch skuts oder so wie das hieß gab es noch den cs commentator der
noch älter ist als ich der wurde entfernt weil er rechtliche probleme mit weil es rechtliche
probleme mit dem emote gab und ansonsten fallen wir gar keine emotes mehr ein die entfernt wurden
na gut also weiter geht's
so wir haben jetzt das git repo ausgecheckt das heißt ich muss jetzt mein package build anpassen
ich muss mein package build anpassen und zwar muss ich die versionsnummer anpassen ich muss die
versionsnummer anpassen auf das was mein aktueller github tag ist lul wurde entfernt ja moment lul
wurde entfernt lul war ein lul war ein better twitch tv emote und das konnten die nicht übernehmen
weil weil der typ keine rechte an seinem eigenen bild hatte sondern der fotograf noch dabei war
und so was war ganz ganz werte werte geschichte so jetzt müssen wir irgendwie uns überlegen wie
wir in bash mit einem seht die versionsnummer hier austauschen vielleicht habt ihr da irgendwie
eine schlaue idee also ich würde sagen wir machen ein seht also vielleicht habt ihr auch eine andere
idee wenn ihr eine coole idee habt sagt bescheid ich habe das git repo noch nicht ausgecheckt das
stimmt das bringt jetzt aber auch an der stelle noch nix weil ich muss noch mein ssh key und so
einfügen da muss ich mal überlegen wie wir das am besten machen so also seht wir wollen was
replace und zwar wollen wir replace package version und zwar im prinzip alles so es wird
package version gelöscht ersetzt durch tja wir sind wir simulieren das jetzt mal kurz export version
gleich 0.0.3 blade dankeschön für den sub wir simulieren das jetzt mal kurz ich habe hier noch
nicht hier lokal die github actions variablen zur verfügung aber wir machen wir hier version
so und jetzt wird es ersetzt ok das könnte das könnte man so machen und jetzt machen wir noch
seht in place auf pkg bild das müsste jetzt an der stelle schon mal ganz gut funktionieren nur
dass wir nicht version benutzen wollen an der stelle sondern github refname was die aktuelle
hacknummer ist vorher müssen wir natürlich noch nach tmp vm champ bin wechseln ja ja den ssh key
muss ich muss ich noch alle echonen ja ja ist nicht schlimm selbst wenn ich den ssh key eschore bis
ihr den abgetippt habt habe ich den schon wieder geändert ich benutze den nämlich nur fürs art
user repo alles klar so vorher muss ich noch das repo immer weg vorher muss ich noch das repo
klonen das können wir ja schon mal simulieren ohne ohne dass ich schreibrechte auf das repo
habe ist alles in ordnung so wir gehen nach zerm ok wir gehen nach zem und dann machen wir
ein klon get klon auf das repo einfach auf gist post da brauchst kein secret 5 hat time so
machen wir das so dann klonen wir das repo hin dann geben wir in das repo rein dann machen wir
uns das sieht danach müssen wir noch folgendes machen ich zeige euch das mal danach muss noch
package oder make make make package minus minus oder fuck weiß ich doch nicht man make package
irgendwas mit info print source info alles klar das brauche ich make package print source info
ah scheiße man darf das als root nicht ausführen ok jetzt bin ich moment ich muss doch ein user
anlegen jetzt dafür oder wie oh nee das macht es wieder unnötig kompliziert das macht es
wieder unnötig kompliziert dass ich das nicht als gut machen darf geht nicht minus minus force
mal ausprobieren nee running make package as root is not allowed as it can cause permanent
catastrophic damage to your system catastrophic damage leute weiß ich warum ich jetzt gachi roll
anmache aber irgendwie war es mit einer catastrophic damage das ist wie wenn er drüber rollt über euch
hier catastrophic damage also das darf man nicht das heißt ich muss noch ein user anlegen oder was
add user gibt es nicht user add sag mal gibt es noch andere leute die das nicht auseinander
halten können ob es jetzt add user oder user add ist glaube add user ist das script was heimat
verzeichnungen alles drumherum anlegt und user add ist das raw kommando ok heißt im endeffekt
auch wir müssen noch einen user dazwischen das ist ja mal richtig eklig ok user add bild nennen wir
das einfach user add bild jetzt haben wir hier den user das heißt vermisst jetzt dieses ok ich
spiele ich spiele das mal durch hier user add bild minus minus es root invalid option keine
chance leute gibt's net man muss es als eigener user machen so das heißt wir machen jetzt sudo
bild sudo minus u bild you don't have right permissions
das ist in der tat wahr das ist aber sehr doof dass ich keine right permissions habe wisst ihr
das das heißt ich muss noch ein ch-own oder sowas davor machen oder ein ch-mod 777 das würde auch
funktionieren ich mach mal ein ch-own ok also machen wir noch ein ch-own davor minus r bild so auf bild
man könnte es theoretisch auch so probieren dass wir user wir machen user root aber gibt
es jetzt eigentlich eine group für den user ok also wir könnten user root group bild sagen wenn
wir da die passenden rechte haben wir haben aber nicht die passenden rechte nice also muss ich
tatsächlich user bild und group root nehmen weil root darf ja prinzipiell alles wobei scheiß drauf
ich gebe das ding ich gebe das verzeichnis dem user bild und der gruppe bild und zwar wollen wir
testen wir jetzt ob das funktioniert und danach machen wir jetzt sudo make package
wie jetzt
was muss man dafür installieren wir installieren einfach ich weiß ja was wir machen wir installieren
einfach base entwicklungstools noch obendrauf jawoll perfekt beim komplett noch obendrauf
nimm als container archlinux ach ist das da schon dabei das ist nice
ist da auch git und sowas schon dabei gucken wir mal docker run archlinux
tibetet hat mich der chat den container gibt es überhaupt nicht
ja es gibt irgendwelche
ach moment du meinst als tech development oder
ah den gibt es nice gut einfach try und error bis man was gefunden hat was funktioniert
ok das ist gut das ist gut und da hat man dann auch git und so nähe das hat man natürlich hat
man ssh drauf nähe hat man auch nicht also den rest muss man schon noch selbst installieren ok
dann probieren das doch jetzt mal aus das heißt wir nehmen hier diesen container und den starten
wir jetzt hier auch und gucken mal ob unsere ich kann immer tippen und gucken mal ob unsere
ab ob unser ablauf irgendwie sinn ergibt von dem was ich da mache also als erstes machen
wir pack mein update dann machen wir pack mein noch konfirm gibt sudo und open ssh ja ok dann
gehen wir nach temp dann klonen wir das git repo dahin dann gehen wir nach vm champion das
hier überspringen wir jetzt ist eigentlich egal komm ich ich ich ich edit ich editiers jetzt einfach
mal von wir haben wir kennen wir drauf wir machen das so muss ich jetzt halt zu tun als bin ich
so dann alter dann machen wir user add bild dann machen wir cf bis jetzt funktioniert alles dann
machen wir zu hauen auf den das temp verzeichnis so und jetzt geht status das jetzt muss ich ok
das ist natürlich test runner wäre jetzt geiler test ich bin mein eigener test runner von hand so
das müssen wir nach source info umleiten ne moment moment moment das müssen wir nicht
nach source info umleiten wir müssen moment sudo das habe ich noch gar nicht hinzugefügt ich
wo habe ich das gemacht hier oben wir müssen machen sudo minus u ich schreibe das mal hier
oben das hier wir müssen jetzt hier an der stelle machen sudo minus u bild was war das was war das
noch mal make package minus minus info hier bild und das dann umleiten und das dann umleiten nach
source info hat funktioniert hat geklappt gucken wir mal ob es funktioniert hat version 3 steht
da drinne ja ok also das müssen wir machen dann müssen wir wieder zurück das ist ja kacke man
dann müssen wir es wieder gut geben wobei nö können wir eigentlich drauf scheiß wir müssen
es nicht gut geben so egal so und jetzt habe ich das editiert wenn ich jetzt geht status
mache doch ich muss es wieder gut geben sonst funktioniert das nicht oder ich muss müsste
alles jetzt mit sudo ausführen was auch bescheuert wäre ich muss es wieder ich muss es wieder gut
geben geht status und jetzt muss ich die sachen kommenten und dann pushen ins user repo so
weit so gut was jetzt muss ich so was machen wie ein das mit dem commit sparen wir uns mal wir
testen jetzt erstmal ob das so weit funktioniert wie ich mir das hier gedacht habe geben wir mal
am ende source info aus und package bild aus und gucken ob das funktioniert jetzt bin ich
mal gespannt ob der krempel auch so eins zu eins in github actions funktioniert was ich hier
gebaut habe alles klar also push lassen wir mal bilden oder machen nach opt so egal ob ich
nach temp oder ob mach der bild champ ok actions auf geht's schauen wir mal so der erste guck jetzt
haben wir auch die zweite action hier schon drinnen beziehungsweise nicht die zweite action den
den den zweiten bild job haben wir jetzt hier drinnen der erste sollte schnell geht weil wir
haben jetzt ist schon durch ist schon durch der erste step kommt der zweite step gucken wir mal
jetzt bin ich gespannt ob das ob das so weit funktioniert wie wir das hier gebaut haben
ja ja mach hinne initialize containers als champ post champ prager leute wir brauchen wieder
sonst wird das nix ok ok ok wie das das ging jetzt oder wie moment package install ja
package based
ja ja funktioniert versionsnummer sv 003 der tag den ich gepusht habe wurde dynamisch eingetragen
das ist gut genauso soll das ganze sein sehr schön so jetzt kommt jetzt kommt allerdings
das komplizierteste wie kriege ich zugriff auf meinen user repo und zwar schreibenden
zugriff nicht nur lesenden zugriff also so also den bild den bild haben wir jetzt ne
erst mal moment moment mein mein erst mal muss ich kommeten erst mal muss ich kommeten das
können wir nämlich noch lokal ausprobieren geht kommet aminus m update heißt es jetzt einfach
das funktioniert jetzt natürlich nicht
weil ich ja das natürlich doof weil ich keine email adresse und so was für geht gesetzt
habe ok das heißt das müssen wir jetzt noch schnell nachholen geht kommet mit das update
so und da kommt auch mal der tag rein in die kommet
wie setzt man denn jetzt hier seine
ich habe eine idee können wir nicht können wir nicht bescheißen können wir nicht bescheißen
anstatt meine email adresse zu setzen leute wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt six hat beschiss
und zwar hier steht es doch schon drinne kann man das nicht einfach wieder verwenden den
autor kann man git clone kommet oder so was machen du kannst email leer lassen ok funkt
funktioniert das wenn ich email adresse leer lasse
wir können wir können den fake fake user setzen ja also username den kenne ich ja schon mal wo
blots den kenne ich der ist das den kriege ich auch den geht den kriege ich auch github github
ja was passiert wenn ich jetzt kommete
mag er nicht das heißt ich sag mal github mail mal gucken wenn ich den leer setze easy
gibt einfach gibt einfach keine email adresse scheiß drauf fertig aus ja
ja das ist easy ok also müssen wir im endeffekt hier noch mal setzen das da
vorher irgendwo vor dem kommet muss man das da setzen und wir müssen die user setzen user
setzen wir aber nicht hardcoded auf wo bloss sondern six hat time github wir holen uns den
usernamen aus dem aktuellen github actions kontext raus da gibt es nämlich so was wie
ohne irgendwo da repository ohne und der soll das der soll das comitten heißt wir wollen an
der stelle so was haben und jetzt repository ohne dann machen wir einen kommet und jetzt müssen
wir pushen jetzt wird es halt jetzt wird es halt kompliziert jetzt muss man es das hake
da irgendwie reinkriegen gilt log minus eins minus p wunderbar wir pushen das noch mal und
gucken ob es bis zu diesem zeitpunkt funktioniert und jetzt muss ich mir überlegen wie ich da
mein ssh key rein bekomme also mein ssh key selbst kann ich euch ja mal zeigen ist kein secret also
den ssh key nicht den zeige ich euch nicht aber ich zeige euch das secret actions ich habe ein
secret our key da ist mein private ssh key drinnen glaube gibt eine action dafür ich mach so was auch
das geht auch mit dem github api key ja gut ich könnte ich könnte einen neuen key generieren
lassen irgendwie für github intern und und den dann im hour hinzufügen das müsste wahrscheinlich
funktionieren ja ob ich was mache also in frankfurt auf jeden fall aber ob 500k sind da bin ich auch
ein bisschen entfernt von aber mit der aktuellen inflationsrate vielleicht mache ich irgendwann
auch mal 500k so schauen wir mal ob die action soweit funktionieren ja sieht gut aus
der fobs infra action push
das bringt mir doch jetzt nicht wirklich was oder
ne der hatte da nicht automatisch der hatte da nicht automatisch magic rechne auf mein branch
auf mein repo ja guck du brauchst trotzdem außerdem von github nach github ich push ja
nicht von github nach github ich pushe ins arch user repo ne das funktioniert nicht ok
es hat aber funktioniert bis dahin und zwar was hat er gemacht committed maintainer wo bloß das
wurde hinzugefügt das wurde geändert sehr schön sehr schick alles gut alles klar da ist da ist
da ist da ist da ist da ist da ist da ist da ist also bis hierhin funktioniert das ganze gut
jetzt muss ich meinen key irgendwie hinzufügen können wir nicht einfach einen ssh agent verwenden
ohne dass ich da muss ich dann gar keine datei anlegen man könnte einfach ssh agent benutzen
wie ging das noch mal ssh agents
einmal eval ssh agent das ist pfeiffer time wie das funktioniert hier eval ssh agent
was nicht ssh agent minus s
was ist minus s
ja ok also was muss man jetzt machen eval ssh agent ne moment moment nicht so sondern so
ssh agent minus s ok dann muss ein ssh key rein das können wir hier unten dann machen das reicht
immer mal das log aus das ist eigentlich ganz gut wie es ist ssh agent so und jetzt müssen
wir dem ssh agent meinen github key zum fressen geben aus einer variable wir machen mal einen
fake key key gleich wir generieren mal einen fake key und gucken ob das funktioniert ssh key
gen er irgendein key mir doch egal ja perfekt genau den will ich haben cd ssh cat leute private key
leak oh nein key leak fresh freshly generated key leak so und jetzt löschen wir ihn wieder
tmp vm champ bin so habe ich den key in der zwischenablage wie bekomme ich den key jetzt
in ssh agent rein ssh agent also normalerweise kann man angeben ssh agent und dann das key file
glaube ich hinten dran ssh agent standard in kriegt man das irgendwie add ssh key vom variable
oh fife hat time was das add ssh key private variable monka es ok hier gleich jetzt brauche
ich diesen shit der muss da rein und jetzt habe ich es kaputt gemacht so und jetzt was key
error warum error echo key
moment muss ich das vielleicht direkt hinten dran schreiben dass es funktioniert oder vielleicht so
ne ne ne so funktioniert es so funktioniert sein ok das ist ja richtig 6 hat time noch ein minus
zu viel ne das muss da sein dass er standard in annimmt an der stelle das ist das symbol für
standard in oder ja stimmt wir können ja auch faken wir können eben auch wir können den auch
aus der name pipe lesen lassen sehr gute idee fife hat time ist der key irgendwie kaputt
weißt du was wir hauen das mal in github actions rein und gucken ob es funktioniert ich mein
wie geht das seek ritz im moment jetzt muss ich das hier wenn das jetzt funktioniert beiß ich
mir ein arsch also nicht nicht wortwörtlich genommen ja secrets secrets
our key so geht das glaube ich busch
so ich werde jetzt mal kurz mein clipboard ausschalten nur für den fall der fälle
our login machen offen zweiten bildschirm nur für den fall der fälle dass ich irgendwelche
irgendwelche keys wirklich leaker
das wollen wir ja nicht und in mein profil gehen und theoretisch den key löschen können wenn es
sein muss so es hat funktioniert ok ja gut es hat keinen error gegeben schon mal also vermute
ich jetzt einfach mal dass es funktioniert hat oder falscher run oh nee shit
command not found ok echo key also wo ist das wo ist er jetzt das problem wie kriegen wir das
jetzt da rein minus so so so und jetzt machen wir es einfach noch mal so zweimal doppelt gemoppelt
guck mal ich habe ich den vielleicht falsch kopiert habe ich den habe ich den key falsch
ok wir erstellen uns noch mal etwas übersichtlicher key ich habe das ende
nicht mit kopiert ok das natürlich ziemlich durf nimmt auch falls dann ich hab doch keine
files das ist doch das problem wenn ich falls hätte wäre das sehr easy jetzt habe generate
keys idee irgendwas kann man das moment nimmt das standard in an der stelle so an ja klar muss
es eigentlich ich erstelle mal kurz noch mal einen neuen key zum testen ja ja wunderbar wunderbar
excellent kath ssh idee den da will ich haben ich habe wahrscheinlich die helfe nicht mit
kopiert der ist jetzt auch ein bisschen umgänglicher cd temp vm champ bin ssh agent
so weil jetzt könnte man könnte man nicht einfach so was hier sagen echo nach ssh agent minus
man ist das scheiße alter warum funktioniert das nicht
wegen dem new line hinten dran vielleicht
das macht ich fertig ok key gleich ach so ach es ist ssh et ich bin ja auch blöd minus
es hat funktioniert nice ok dann machen wir das jetzt so also easy easy echo minus n viel besser
so sehr gut sehr schön sehr schön so war das jetzt so und jetzt das pushen das pushen spare ich
mir an der stelle noch ich will ich will gucken ob es funktioniert ok jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
jetzt warten bis dieser bis der run hier startet chat wir brauchen eine runde prager support
prager support im chat dass es funktioniert prager time ohne ohne ohne mindestens fünf
prager emote wird das nix hast du gerade den ssh key nicht geliegt nö ich habe einen frisch
generierten ssh key geliegt ok da ist genug prager am besten wenn natürlich man macht für
sowas im base container wo das alles schon drin ist ja und und und und und fuck man alter wo ist
das problem ey boah wo ist das problem man error loading key vom standard in
hab es auch genauso gemacht wie hier secrets our key ist der key den valid ich würde mal
von ausgehen ich habe den da einfach ich kann ihn euch jetzt ja nicht zeigen
habe ich das richtig geschrieben
ok was gibt es was gibt es sonst noch für möglichkeiten wenn das wenn das so nicht geht
können wir dann kann man denn dann auch das ganze ok probieren wir es mal umgedreht
probieren wir es mal noch mal so und jetzt hier mit in kombination echo jetzt wird es etwas
funktioniert auch ok dann machen wir es noch mal so ssh add und jetzt was minus minus minus
3 n error time leute
secrets
punkt ok
push jetzt aber let's go
wenn das jetzt funktioniert habe ich gar keine ahnung warum das ist eigentlich mehr oder
weniger equivalent zu dem was ich vorher gemacht habe ewal ssh agent habe ich doch
habe ich habe ich vergessen nö ist doch richtig doch alles gut
freige time einfach funktionieren jetzt geht ab actions please
ja ja setze mal den job ab freige freige freige freige
das ging ok warum geht das und das vorher ging nicht das vorher war noch viel schöner
ok das müssen wir jetzt mal irgendwie das super krasse linux pro erklären dann der
noch mehr ahnung hat warum geht ok moment moment also nur mal so zu wir vergleichen
das jetzt mal wir vergleichen das jetzt mal ok warum geht das oben und warum geht das
unten nicht vermutlich weil action echo von secrets verbietet auf irgendeine weise aber
hier mache ich auch ein echo davor war ein echo minus n echo minus n ist eigentlich die
bessere variante weil das kein extra new line hinten dran macht und es hat hier unten auch
funktioniert das an der minus n wird es nicht liegen im moment ich bin auch blöd
war das wirklich das was ich vorhin dastehen hatte ne oder das das hatte ich das hatte ich
vorhin dastehen blödsinn was ich da kopiert habe also das da versus das da ich habe es vielleicht
vielleicht unterdrückt das vielleicht unterdrückt das github wirklich vielleicht filter die das oder
so weil für mich sieht das ok das hier ist halt bash redirektion magic ich habe legit keine ahnung
was ist was es da macht ja hier liest halt standart in und hier liest ja eigentlich auch
standart in was auch immer es funktioniert das ist die hauptsache gut nice gg jetzt sind wir
eigentlich bereit zum comiten das lasse wir nehmen wir haben alles wir haben kommet jetzt
könnte man eigentlich pushen da muss man aber das richtige repo nehmen zum pushen und zwar ich
suche das richtige repo mal kurz raus wenn hier nehmen muss das da muss man da nehmen
post key check vom hour moment ja wir sind wir sind doch noch nicht ganz fertig weil ich
vermute mal dass das geht klohne an der stelle nicht funktionieren wird immer tmp rm vorm
hier geht klohn ja man muss man muss diesen ganzen krempel akzeptieren
ok also wollen wir haben geht klohn und im vorfeld wollen wir das ein bisschen überschreiben
weiß exzellent ist der golfer flow google google stellt alles klar was müssen wir machen geht
kommand exzellent der chat weiß wie man es macht geht kommand minus ssh also im prinzip
so no strict aus key checking user sehr gut genauso will ich das haben nur dass ich diesen
krempel davor machen muss sonst funktioniert ziemlich nett oder kann man nämlich ja das ist
das ok so können übrigens dieses ganze geht setup zeug hier oben machen das ist das das
durch ist da kann man das nämlich ein bisschen ja das ist das quasi hier geht setup
macht doch export für später push ja ja wahrscheinlich gar nicht so verkehrt
sport
ok dann schauen wir mal ob das funktioniert das heißt er müsste das jetzt klohn und
er müsste das auch schon mit dem richtigen ssh key machen so dass ich so dass es keinen
fehler gibt beim klohn das probieren wir jetzt noch mal aus und wenn das geht können wir
eigentlich die neue version pushen ich denke das passt glaube ich glaube das glaube das ist es
das müsste dann gehen
gib ihm
nicht so langsam
ah jetzt
ok gucken wir mal ob das jetzt funktioniert
jaa sehr gut sehr gut sehr gut sehr gut sehr gut
es hat alles funktioniert würde ich sagen
kann ich das jetzt einfach per yay installieren
ja kannst du kannst du jetzt schon
allerdings dann kannst du immer die aktualisierten versionen auch per
also kannst du es jetzt schon hier guck mal
das ist meins und das ist das vom vorti wo immer die aktuellste version gebildet wird
hier ist die aktuelle release version
so also das hat wie es aussieht funktioniert
der macht hier installieren dependencies
create temporary filepla wo ist das denn hier
ja ja funktioniert funktioniert ok nice
pogu extremely pogu
ich würd sagen
jetzt fehlt eigentlich nur noch das pushen von dem repo
jetzt müssen wir gucken dass wir auch die neueste version pushen
update build jammel
ja der pull request und so ist schon dabei fix fix fix all mal images
vielleicht können wir noch ein paar weitere pull requests dabei hauen auf die schnelle
wobei gibt ja keinen
gibt ja den der ist der ist groß den muss ich mir erstmal angucken
ja
update readme
hab ich da alles gehabt update update
vielleicht soll ich jetzt mal ein ordentliches
vielleicht soll ich da mal ein ordentliches ordentliches comment draus machen
das ist ja wirklich nicht nicht
gescheit zu lesen hier
habe ich nicht irgendwo noch im master
get check out master
pull getter was
hatte ich nicht irgendwie da noch was drinne
update readme update readme
habe ich nicht irgendwo gestern noch die
die message im ssh
command gefixt
die war nicht so schön
nee hab ich anscheinend nicht gepusht
nee die hab ich das hab ich anscheinend noch nicht gepusht
ich hatte die message hier gefixt ich hab da reingeschrieben connecting to und so ein
flugzeug emoji reingemacht
ja dann machen wir das doch jetzt schnell noch
das rechtfertigt dann selbstverständlich version 0.0.3
easy
ok
also jetzt machen wir das mal ein bisschen ordentlich
get check out def
get cherry-v master
macht folgendes
zeigt alle comments an die in diesem branche drin sind
aber nicht in master
das heißt das sind meine letzten bastel comments
sieht man ja auch hier
update
update bildjaml bildjaml und davor habe ich irgendwie noch temp und sowas drin
können wir uns auch anzeigen lassen was da drinne ist
git log
minus minus p
so nur updates am workflow
updates am docker image das muss ich auf jeden fall auch im master pushen dann
update am workflow update am workflow und temp name bild alles klar
ja dann fassen wir das mal zusammen zu einem ordentlichen comment
get reset
get commit
so das heißt jetzt nicht temp das commit sondern das heißt edit git lab
action cia
workflow
for our build
so jetzt haben wir ein comment wo alles schön benannt ist und auch alle
änderungen enthält
also so kann man das machen selbst wenn man in branche hat mit
150.000 temp temp temp comments
da habe ich git lab geschrieben
ja aber auch wenn man in branche hat mit ganz vielen eklichen comments so kann
man das ganz gut zusammenfassen einfach resetten auf das erste comment
und dann anhängen alles und die comment message ändern das geht natürlich nur
in eigenen branches also in irgendwelchen public branches wo noch mehr leute
mitarbeiten würde ich euch das nicht empfehlen so zu machen und da würde ich
euch nicht empfehlen 140 temp comments rein zu pushen
das ist quasi das ist
es ist quasi so was wie ein rebase
rebase macht das ja rebase macht ja das gleiche
rebase macht ein reset
und dann cherry picks der reihe nach
ist im prinzip das gleiche
gibt ein paar wege wie man das machen kann
ich glaube jetzt passt alles soweit
ich würde sagen wir können das in master mal rüber picken
lokal erst einmal
git checkout master
ja
passt doch alles gut
git checkout master
git merge def
so und jetzt passe ich die eine sache hier noch an was der neue version
rechtfertigt nämlich
wir machen ein schönes hilfbefehl
kommt es nicht einfach an der stelle console right line nein nein nein das ist
nix
da kommt jetzt console
mark up line
ganz hübsch und zwar
connect
zu
po m name
und jetzt müssen wir uns
moment warum warum mache ich eigentlich so ich kann doch hier mein mein ovel
connect to und jetzt muss da an der stelle
ein emoji
ein
plane hin
airplane
und jetzt ist das version 0.0.3 eindeutig
also ich finde
diese meldung macht jetzt schon mal
viel besser das ist auf jeden fall ein neuer versionssprung wert
wert
jetzt
jutsch changes
so bestes bestes kommets
lizenz
du hast recht
lizenz können wir auch noch machen
ist das gerade die kommando zeile von artis gewesen also vanilla oder irgendwie
custom was denn das hier meinst du oder was das da
oder wie oder was was was
jetzt blick ich nicht durch
was denn genau
also das hier ist custom kommando zeile
da ist einiges dran custom heißt
das emoji das ist rofi das ist der emoji
das ist der emoji picker aus rofi
leider kann er keine twitch emotes
das sollte eigentlich mal jemand
jemand einfügen rofi
twitch emote gibt es da schon was
moment
das was anderes
sind auch nur emojis
der kann keine twitch emotes
der faked der faked dass er twitch emotes kann aus irgendwelchen gründen
mein google dass es twitch emotes kann
alles gut so also jetzt haben wir den kram gemerged jetzt können wir das pushen
get push origin
wobei nicht origin github master
gucken wir mal ob das ganze angekommen ist
jetzt haben wir die workflows auch hier im
master drin
soll ich mache jetzt ein test ran noch mal ob das ob das funktioniert
wenn das funktioniert dann pushen wir pushen wir die version ins
user user repo
das brauchen wir nicht mehr
als tag
fake fake tag 3 drauf machen
ich habe nichts groß geändert sollte eigentlich
huge changes gibt es jetzt
ich könnte bei der gelegenheit mal
wo wir gerade dabei sind ich während der während der run läuft
das muss ja nicht muss ja nicht unbedingt da drin sein
wenn man das nicht von hand machen will man kann die github actions
äh nicht die github man kann die github
das github cli tool verwenden für solche geschichten
da kann man dann auch schleifen drum bauen und und so was
man kann auch den cash komplett klären
da muss man nicht hier von hand sinnlos rumklicken so wie ich das
gerade machen
so huge changes sind am start
huge changes also da muss ja kurz
ok der muss jetzt das container image zumindest zum teil
neu bauen logischerweise
weil er hatte die software neu kompiliert ja das dauert jetzt kurz
dauert jetzt ein bisschen länger
der muss er genau
jetzt muss er den cash wieder exportieren
dauert jetzt dauert ein bisschen länger
und jetzt könnte man noch gucken
wie man automatisiert github releases erstellt
ach so eine lizenz muss ja auch noch rein habe ich ganz
wieder ganz vergessen
ok
alle was macht der denn da so lang
was macht der denn da so lange
ok
ok hat alles funktioniert nice
das heißt wir fügen jetzt noch eine lizenz hinzu
und dann ist gut
make package hat alles funktioniert
yo version 3
wunderbar ok hatte github nicht
sowas drinne wo man hatten die nicht so sogar so
ein lizenz picker mittlerweile dabei
anscheinend nicht oder ach jedoch
da ist es doch
choose a license template
oh komm gpl
ne was haben wir denn die unlicensed
ach ne hier ist doch
public was haben wir denn jetzt auch so
gpl 3 oder mit
mit ist im prinzip du darfst alles damit
machen du musst auch die leute nicht mal erwähnen oder sonst wie was
ok
was ist der unterschied zwischen gpl
conditions license und copyright
notice
close source same license
wir nehmen gpl nicht dass noch einer auf
die idee kommt fette stonks zu machen mit dem
vm jam so geht es ja nicht
davon abgesehen ist es egal weil die
destroyer wahrscheinlich dann wenn das einer machen sollte
als so verwenden in irgendwas größerem
komm
alles spammt spammt erst mal schön
alles voll oder
glaube es geht los direkt auf master
alter
so
haben wir auch am start
ok gut dann bleibt uns jetzt ja abschließend
nur noch
ok das release anlegen können wir vielleicht danach noch gucken
aber uns bleibt jetzt ja an der stelle eigentlich nur noch das
pushen ins user repo und gucken ob das
funktioniert
passen wir dann passen wir das doch jetzt mal an
so das heißt wir brauchen am ende jetzt nur noch einen push
und hoffen dass es dann funktioniert geht push
origin
ach so wie heißt denn die fall branche bei denen
sind sind es noch master
enjoyer sind auch master enjoyer
ok geht push origin
master
so ich hoffe das funktioniert jetzt
alles so
wie ich mir das gedacht habe
kommet
aber push
tag
gut
gucken wir mal ob es funktioniert
jetzt bin ich gespannt
das dauert jetzt ein bisschen weil er die software
neu bei muss er die software überhaupt neu bauen ja muss er
weil sich die quell code dateien
geändert haben
nee musst du es nicht oder es ging es ging
auf jeden fall deutlich schneller jetzt
schauen wir mal jetzt jetzt bin ich gespannt
das sollte jetzt gleich v003 sein wenn alles
funktioniert wahrscheinlich klappt irgendwas
wieder nicht irgendwas ist immer
auf schitt hab
boom boom boom
ich finde es immer geil wie schön schnell pack man
ist
ok ok ok
hat funktioniert
version 3
ich habe aber ich habe
den cash von glaub gar nicht gelöscht ich habe die
bilds gelöscht
version 3
ok testen wir gleich mal ob er aber was erkennt
da ist nothing to do was ist da los warum
wahrscheinlich weil es aber noch nicht gesüngt hat
aber
ok
hat noch nicht geupdatet würde ich sagen
es hat noch nicht er hat noch nicht erkannt dass es
geupdatet wurde
vielleicht brauchen die auch ein paar minuten bis es
ja dann warten wir noch mal kurz
mal gucken mal gucken
postchamp machen wir jetzt
postchamp
wird mir noch irgendwann raid limited wenn man das zu oft probiert
ich lasse mal ich lasse mal die finger von weg
wir gucken
wir gucken jetzt mal in das repo rein in das
our repo
ja kann ich dir sagen schreiker
ja das hat funktioniert
also zumindest hat das committed
also während wir warten kann ich es erklären
wir haben ein arch user repo angelegt für den
vm-champ haben die github actions erweitert
dass die ein arch user repo package bauen
können und es anschließend pushen also jedes
mal wenn ich einen tag pushe dann
wenn ich einen tag pushe dann baut der
das da unten kann übrigens zumachen dann baut
er die software zusammen mit dem richtigen tag drauf
und danach baut er ein arch user
repo package zusammen und pusht das
kann es sein dass der download noch nicht da ist ja darauf
warte ich jetzt ja selbst
also hier hat das schon aktualisiert
aber im arch user repo selbst
im champo hat das noch nicht erkannt
ich glaube wir müssen einfach warten
heute heute mittag das erste mal hat es auch
ein paar minuten gedauert
beim github link gibt es ein 404
nö
gibt es nicht
ah
da gibt es einen 404 ja natürlich weil ich
noch gar kein release erstellt habe
low iq leute
das release gibt es ja noch gar nicht
ich muss also
das release gibt es ja noch gar nicht das muss
ich auch noch anlegen das muss ich aber eigentlich
auch automatisch anlegen sonst funktioniert
es ja nicht
wie legt man ein github release an
per github actions also aber er sollte
zumindest mal ein update zu bringen so langsam
aber sicher oder
ganz schön lahm gerade
refresh mirros
ja habe ich ja gemacht
nö
bei mir bei mir hat das doch nicht
bei mir das noch nicht gecheckt dass sich das
aktualisiert hat aber es hat sich aktualisiert
weil das ist ein
auslöser
dass ich das aktualisiert hat aber es hat sich aktualisiert weil hier ist die
neue version drin
gut wir müssen auf jeden fall noch ein release anlegen sonst wird das ja
natürlich so gar nichts das repository hat es geschafft ja toll
ist es irgendwie ziemlich outdated overrated oder
warum ist das warum warum haben die so ein essenzielles feature keine offizielle
action für create release es ist doch bescheuert
was haben was haben wir hier für alternativen von irgendwelchen randoms
ok februar last week ok das ist das ist das ist sehr beliebt das scheint das beliebteste zu
sein hier
below ist es simpel example
release ja ja schön und gut und
kann man es mittlerweile aktualisieren
jetzt hat das leute jetzt hat das so und wenn ich jetzt wenn ich jetzt versuche zu
installieren
dann kackt er ab dabei wahrscheinlich
ne
ich hätte aber erwartet dass er abkackt weil das release gibt es noch nicht
ok
wait a minute warum funkt jetzt bin ich verwirrt warum funktioniert das jetzt
warum geht das jetzt weil ich nicht clean bild gemacht habe oder ok
vor m jam minus minus version 0 2 ist es noch ok
vor m jam bin
das geht bei mir auch nicht ich installiere noch mal und
hä warum ist es jetzt wieder 0 0 2 jetzt blicke ich nicht mehr durch
was zum
ich blicke nicht mehr durch warum wird es jetzt nur noch als version 2 angezeigt
äh
das ist aber das alte
kann man
andere cashing
jetzt ok jetzt ist es drei wir machen jetzt clean bild clean bild yes das sollte
jetzt ah jetzt geht es kaputt ok
ok alles gut jetzt jetzt ergibt das sinn jetzt ergibt das ok das release gibt es
nichts das das passt ja das release gibt es nicht ok gut
dann gucken wir uns doch mal schnell an wie macht man wie macht man so eine
so kiranische für den sub wie macht man denn in github release damit ja gut aber
ich muss doch da zum beispiel den text eindragen können und so was
mit files release txt
probieren das mal aus ja wir probieren das einfach mal aus
also
den step
den step können wir hier als letztes dann tatsächlich durchführen
den müssen wir müssen wir nicht im ourstep durchführen so release platter
if starts was geht hab ref ref text den check kann ich mir sparen weil das geht
nur auf tech pushes
so ist files release txt ja aber was passiert denn dann kann man da nicht
kann man da nicht irgendeinen
automatisch erstellen
ja body kann ich reinschreiben body
also da könnte ich da könnte ich jetzt zum beispiel wobei moment ich will ja da
ich will ja da gar keinen statischen statischen text reinschreiben
das muss ich mir überlegen wie wir das am besten machen
aktuell jetzt jetzt machen wir es mal easy mode
fixes muss reichen fixes weiß jeder bescheid was passiert ist was hast du gepatcht
fixes ok alles klar
so ich hoffe das reicht jetzt weil in der in im beispiel im beispiel ist es
nicht mehr
falls zu tech namen ja moment ich muss noch ich muss noch die
datei anhängen an das release ich muss ich muss noch die datei anhängen
acid upload hier files
files muss ich da noch dranhängen
ok falls will ich ja im prinzip nur
das hier haben
und wo müssen wo müssen die dateien liegen
wo müssen die dateien also kann ich jetzt irgendwas hier hochladen ich meine ich
habe bild ich habe ein bild hier in temp out
wir probieren es wir probieren es jetzt einfach mal aus ob das ob das geht
ich lasse es jetzt einfach mal so laufen man weinert weinert
geht kommet
geht kommet minus aminus m
ich habe release action push faster
jetzt machen wir noch mal lassen wir den tech noch mal pushen
ich vermute mal dass es so was ist was man nicht machen sollte mit dem tech noch
mal pushen weil dann hat man quasi die tippen
das gleiche das gleiche doppelt gepusht was
was ist wahrscheinlich dann verwirrt aber ok
hauptsache hauptsache der legt jetzt ein release an
fack alter wo ist das problem
release fällt mit status 403 ok sehr schön warum man weiß es nicht
muss man vielleicht auch die passenden permissions
ok ich habe jetzt die passenden permissions
this action requires the following permissions
das ist ja schön und gut dass es permissions braucht
aber wäre es nicht sinnvoll gewesen das auch in das beispiel reinzuschreiben
nur mal so rein
nur so gefragt also
contents right
ich push das jetzt noch mal
push origin master force in your face
eigentlich ist es nicht origin
ja examples sind extrem overrated outdated debated
ok
startup failure
was
ja
ich habe contents doppelt drinne stehen ich kack noob
lull hd
so jetzt aber jetzt aber jetzt haben wir jetzt haben wir ein release
ok
break it time
release release ready
release ready version 003 fixes
ah da ist das feil dran sehr gut sehr gut das feil heißt aber noch falsch
das feil heißt noch falsch das müssen wir auf jeden fall noch fixen dass das feil richtig heißt
ich lösche das release noch mal weil ich mir nicht sicher bin was passiert wenn man releases doppelt anlegt
ich glaube da kommt da dann ein bisschen durcheinander
ok das feil heißt noch falsch das heißt wir brauchen jetzt hier noch einen weiteren
weiteren dings denn wir nehmen jetzt einfach dest vm champ wird umbenannt in
temp out so
so
so jetzt heißt das ding richtig und jetzt sollte dann ich hänge das hänge das einfach wieder an hier push egal
und jetzt sollte das auch als release funktionieren das gibt einen fehler warum
doch
ich habe tatsächlich ja oder cp habe ich vergessen nach dem können aber eigentlich
habe ich danach noch irgendwie drauf zu
ja ja ok ich ich muhle es nicht ich muhle es nicht ich kopiere es
ja wieder wieder absolute best practices massig kommens amenden und force pushen so macht man das
und text tausend mal überschreiben und text 500 mal überschreiben wobei text ja eigentlich was eindeutiges sein sollen aber
ok tag
ja
bild release dann bilden mal upload das binary machen release uploading release
release ready at und jetzt release drei release now
die github seite ist kaputt vm champ linux v003 amd 64 ok jetzt sollte eigentlich moment was passiert
denn jetzt eigentlich in der weiteren bild action wenn ich jetzt noch mal eine sache wenn ich jetzt das das doppelt hinzufüge
der schlägt fehl was aber auch ok ist weil es hat sich ja nichts geändert das ist gar nicht so schlecht dass der fehl schlägt
leute das ist gar nicht so schlecht der schlägt fehl weil das was ich ende exakt also der output ist exakt der gleiche
ok vm champ
vm champ bin
yes yes
jawoll
dazu kann man nur sagen
eindeutig
easy
easy clap
vm champ
bin
ok
go
ja doch ich mache es jetzt zweizeitig
also wir haben was haben wir denn für changes gemacht
better
message
for
ss
connect
keine ahnung
was haben wir sonst noch?
haben wir sonst irgendwas sinnvolles noch gemacht?
ah picks
nein
ich kann nicht schreiben
image
links
gut
push
ok
jetzt können wir das überprüfen
ob da was ordentliches reinkommt
als vierer really
bin ich mal gespannt ich bin jetzt mal gucken
ob das
funktioniert
mit mehrzeiligen sachen
das wäre auf jeden fall extrem nice wenn das funktioniert
weil da muss ich gar nichts mehr machen
da mache ich einfach ein ordentliches
commit
und dann mache ich einen tag drauf und push das
und es sieht
einfach dann sofort hübsch aus
ohne dass ich was machen muss
zack
wie nice
das ist cool das gefällt mir wenn man die letzte
man könnte auch
einen changelog file machen
dann
dann müsste man das nicht in die komme
aber das ist cool das mag ich
das gefällt mir
sehr sehr nice
so das
schlägt jetzt fehl weil es das ganze
schon gibt wird jetzt
abkacken aber das ist auch in ordnung
eine
sache müssen wir danach aber noch machen
das muss auch ein bisschen
muss auch ein bisschen hübscher gemacht werden
im repo wir müssen nämlich noch hier leute
eine badge für das
user repo und den last
build hin machen
die coolen leute in ihren repos haben alle hier so
eine build badge
ist natürlich doof wenn dann da steht build failing
naja
willst du machen
so jetzt mal gucken ob mittlerweile
das arch user repo das ganze
gecheckt hat aha
guckt mal da der vm champ wird
geupdatet
vm champ
minus minus version
muss ich clean build machen
muss man
ein clean build machen dass das
funktioniert
aber warum
ja warum muss ich
das verstehe ich nicht
warum muss ich
ein clean build machen damit das funktioniert
das ist ziemlich
ja kack
muss ich dafür vielleicht
checksum einfügen
dass er es kapiert oder
warum checkt er nicht dass es
ein neues package gibt
da meint doch einer das was net
gelöscht wird
ne das wird jetzt nicht sein
next pick idea moin
aber wir haben jetzt auch auto
complete ok
sehr schön sehr schick
warum muss ich
das verstehe ich nicht
only update
clean build
ja das verstehe ich nicht
warum
warum er das nicht
updateet
das leuchtet
ich meine es funktioniert ja prinzipiell
weil ich clean build machen muss aber
warum
keine ahnung
zumindest eine
sache müssen wir jetzt noch machen das müssen wir uns
das müssen wir uns dann immer mal im detaill angucken warum das nicht
warum das nicht geht
weil das ist ja blöd
wenn es nur beim clean build funktioniert
denkt doch dran dass er dann clean build machen muss
wahrscheinlich ist das package file einfach
nicht richtig
was ich da erstellt habe
woran könnte das denn liegen
dass er das nicht checkt
ich meine hier sind eindeutig die versionsnummern
drin und hier wird die versionsnummer
geupdatet also
muss man vielleicht
package release hoch machen
ich dachte das package release
bezieht sich moment
vielleicht bezieht sich das
package release nicht auf
das release mit der gleichen versionsnummer
sondern damit das überhaupt funktioniert
muss man das hoch machen
ok
was ist das
das
das build passiert ja auf github
da ist ja ein clean vergessen nicht möglich
ne das build passiert nicht
auf github
das build passiert bei jedem
lokal die software wird auf github
gebaut dieses package installieren
das passiert das passiert also das
was hier in diesem package build drinne steht
das passiert bei jedem lokal auf
der kiste der sich das
package installiert
aber warum
warum er das nicht checkt
da muss ich mich mal schlaum an
da ist bestimmt in meinem buildfile irgendwas
verkehrt
weiß jemand von euch
nummer nummer so
downgrade gab es doch hier
downgrade
ja
ja ja
ich will das nochmal
nachstellen downgrade
vor mchamp
vor mchamp bin
geht das so
ah shit
das das geht
das geht glaube ich nicht
glaub das
glaub das geht nicht oder
ok ne das geht nicht
kannst nach was
cash
vor mchamp bin
ja ich hab ja clean
build gemacht
das ist jetzt das ist jetzt weg
install
old
our version wie macht man das
hab ich mir noch nie
noch nie gedanken drüber gemacht version
ja das package build kann ich runterladen
das ist mir klar
ja gut
dann heißt das aber anders
oder
kann ich jetzt
ok
könnte könnte ich jetzt
das alte aus checken
also git log
also mal lokal lokal ich
ok ich uninstall das mal
vor mchamp
yes
pull
so und jetzt gehen wir mal hier bei mir lokal
git reset
minus minus hard einfach eins
zurück das ist jetzt das dreier
build ok
make
package
minus minus install
yes
vor mchamp minus minus version
ist wieder der dreier
so und wenn ich das jetzt so mach
dann bietet er mir das an
ok so kann man das nachstellen
das ist doch schon mal gut
was ich jetzt überhaupt nicht checke ist
so
das ist
ok
so
ganz wichtig
easy
Easy
Ready